This episode is brought to you by the Lloyd's 5K house deposit, and this is something that was last seen in 1996. Yeah, so the 1990s looks now like a lost golden age of prosperity and positivity, doesn't it? Think of the sort of the advent of the Blair administration in 1997, all the enthusiasm and excitement that surrounded that, the economic growth at the time, the technological developments, the sort of sense of an endless golden summer where everybody is listening to Blair an oasis and looking forward to buying their first houses and that of course takes us to mortgages. Now the good news is that in a nod to the 1990s, Lloyds are offering 5K deposit mortgages to first-time buyers. So search 5K first-time buyer.
本期节目由劳埃德银行（Lloyd's）5K房屋首付贷款赞助播出，这项服务上一次出现还是在1996年。没错，现在的20世纪90年代看起来就像是一个失落的繁荣与积极的黄金时代，不是吗？想想1997年布莱尔政府上台时的情景，那种围绕着它的热情和兴奋，当时的经济增长，技术的发展，那种仿佛无尽的黄金之夏的感觉，每个人都在听着布莱尔和绿洲乐队（Oasis）的歌，期待着购买他们的第一套房子，而这自然就把我们引向了抵押贷款。现在好消息是，为了向90年代致敬，劳埃德银行为首次购房者提供了5000英镑首付的抵押贷款。所以，搜索“5K首次购房者”即可。
1996 average first-time buyer deposits are based on ONS data. Subject to status, your home may be repossessed if you don't keep up repayments. and conditions apply. This episode is sponsored by Ancestry. The First World War doesn't just survive in monuments and history books. It survives in smaller things too. Forms, ledgers, service numbers and addresses. Those are the details that can make family history feel less distant.
1996年的平均首次购房者首付是基于英国国家统计局（ONS）的数据。需视个人情况而定，如果您未能按时还款，您的房屋可能会被收回。条款适用。本期节目由Ancestry赞助。第一次世界大战不仅仅存在于纪念碑和历史书中，它也存在于更细微的事物中。表格、账本、服役编号和地址。正是这些细节，让家族史感觉不再那么遥远。
A surname you recognise, a regiment, the detail that brings a family story into focus. More than 5 million men served in the British Armed Forces. during the First World War. And for many British families, that war is just a few generations away. July marks the 110th anniversary of the Battle of the Somme. It is a time not just to look at the scale of that story, but the individual lives behind it. Visit Ancestry.com.com.
一个你熟悉的姓氏，一个团，这些细节让家族故事变得清晰起来。第一次世界大战期间，有超过500万名男子在英国武装部队服役。对于许多英国家庭来说，那场战争距离现在只有几代人的时间。七月是索姆河战役110周年纪念。这不仅是一个审视那个故事规模的时刻，也是一个审视其背后个体生命的时刻。请访问Ancestry.com。
And search First World War military records to discover your family's role in the First World War. Your summer travels deserve an upgrade. With select Chevrolet, Buick, GMC, and Cadillac vehicles connected by OnStar, you can stream, game, and more on the go. Whether you're headed to a music festival or a cottage getaway, you can access hundreds of apps on Google Play right from your center display.
并搜索第一次世界大战军事记录，以发现您的家族在第一次世界大战中的角色。您的夏季旅行值得升级。通过OnStar连接的精选雪佛兰、别克、GMC和凯迪拉克汽车，您可以在旅途中进行流媒体播放、游戏等操作。无论您是前往音乐节还是去度假小屋，都可以直接从中央显示屏访问Google Play上的数百个应用程序。
Explore OnStar Tech Today at OnStar.ca and discover how to take your summer to the next level. OnStar. Better never stops. This letter, my very dear Eliza, will not be delivered to you unless I shall first have terminated my earthly career to begin, as I humbly hope from redeeming grace and divine mercy, a happy immortality. If it had been possible for me to have avoided the interview, my love for you and my precious children would have been alone a decisive motive. but it was not possible without sacrifices which would have rendered me unworthy of your esteem.
立即在OnStar.ca探索OnStar技术，了解如何将您的夏季体验提升到一个新的水平。OnStar，追求卓越永无止境。这封信，我最亲爱的伊丽莎，除非我先结束了我的尘世生涯，否则不会交到你手中，我谦卑地希望，从救赎的恩典和神圣的怜悯中，开始一种幸福的不朽。如果我有可能避免这次会面，我对你和你珍贵的孩子们的热爱本将是唯一的决定性动机，但如果不做出牺牲，我就无法做到这一点，而那些牺牲会使我不配得到你的尊重。
I need not tell you of the pangs I feel, from the idea of quitting you and exposing you to the anguish which I know you would feel. Fly to the bosom of your God and be comforted. With my last idea, I shall cherish the sweet hope of meeting you in a better world. world. Adieu, best of wives and best of women. Embrace all my darling children for me, ever yours, Alexander Hamilton. So that was the farewell letter written by Alexander Hamilton to his wife, Eliza, and he wrote it exactly a week before his fatal duel with Aaron Burr on the 11th of July 1804. And I think that for anyone today who may be inspired to challenge someone to a duel, it's an excellent model. And I think that should one day, I similarly find myself writing to
我无需告诉你，想到要离开你，让你面对我知道你会感到的痛苦，我心中所感受到的煎熬。飞向你上帝的怀抱，得到安慰吧。带着我最后的念头，我将珍藏着在更好的世界与你重逢的甜蜜希望。永别了，最好的妻子，最好的女人。替我拥抱我所有亲爱的孩子们，永远属于你的，亚历山大·汉密尔顿。这就是亚历山大·汉密尔顿写给妻子伊丽莎的诀别信，他写于1804年7月11日与阿隆·伯尔进行致命决斗的前一周。我认为，对于今天任何可能受到启发去挑战别人决斗的人来说，这是一个极好的榜样。我想，如果有一天，我也发现自己写信给
my own beloved wife, Sadie, announcing my intention to fight a duel, I shall sign myself of Thomas Holland and capital letters, which is what Alexander Hamilton did there. Dominic, we haven't really done many duels on the rest of history. In fact, I don't think we've done any, have we? And this is an absolutely banger with which to kick off the history of duels on the rest is history. Undoubtedly, the most celebrated duel in American history, perhaps in all of history. And Henry Adams called it the most dramatic moment in the early politics of the Union. And it's, I guess, kind of reached a new audience over the past few years because it's featured very prominently in a celebrated musical, hasn't it?
我深爱的妻子萨迪，宣布我打算进行决斗，我也会像亚历山大·汉密尔顿那样，用大写字母签下托马斯·霍兰德的名字。多米尼克，我们在《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）中并没有真正进行过很多决斗。事实上，我想我们一次都没做过，对吧？而这绝对是一个以极佳方式开启《历史的其余部分》中决斗史的开端。毫无疑问，这是美国历史上，也许是整个历史上最著名的决斗。亨利·亚当斯称其为联邦早期政治中最具戏剧性的时刻。我想，在过去几年里，它已经触及了新的受众，因为它在一部著名的音乐剧中占据了非常突出的位置，不是吗？
It has Lin-Manuel Miranda's hip-hop musical. so that opened off-Broadway in 2015. And Lim Manuel Miranda, he's had a lot of praise, so we should introduce the tiny note of criticism, so he doesn't get too big-headed. The one mistake he made was not to emulate your tremendous accent work there with the portrayal of Hamilton, because, of course, Hamilton would have spoken with a slightly comical,
确实，林-曼努埃尔·米兰达的嘻哈音乐剧。该剧于2015年在百老汇外开演。林-曼努埃尔·米兰达获得了许多赞誉，所以我们应该引入一点小小的批评，这样他就不会太自负了。他犯的唯一错误就是没有效仿你在这里扮演汉密尔顿时的那种惊人的口音，因为当然，汉密尔顿说话时会带有一种略显滑稽的、
semi-Scottish, semi-Caribbean, but ultimately West Country voice, wouldn't he? Like all Americans. Yes, which is what I was evoking there. I think it's fair to say that an emmer. emphasis on strict realism isn't a keynote of the musical, is it? No, it's true. In some ways, it was an unexpected triumph because Alexander Hamilton is not the most celebrated of the founding fathers.
半苏格兰、半加勒比，但最终是英国西南部口音，不是吗？像所有美国人一样。是的，这就是我刚才所唤起的。我认为公平地说，对严格现实主义的强调并不是这部音乐剧的基调，对吧？不，这是真的。在某些方面，这是一个意想不到的胜利，因为亚历山大·汉密尔顿并不是开国元勋中最著名的一位。
But of course, the duel is a really great moment. And the jewel is a good story. The jewel's a brilliant window into the factionalism of the 1790s, the factionalism that follows American independence in 1776. So you've got the rivalry between Hamilton's Federalists and top villain Thomas Jefferson's Democratic Republicans. Well, you say top villain, we're going to be looking at him in our next episode. You know my views.
但当然，决斗是一个非常伟大的时刻。决斗是一个好故事。决斗是洞察1790年代派系斗争的一扇绝佳窗口，即1776年美国独立后随之而来的派系斗争。所以你有汉密尔顿的联邦党人和头号反派托马斯·杰斐逊的民主共和党人之间的竞争。好吧，你说头号反派，我们将在下一集中讨论他。你知道我的观点。
I know your views, but people can find out mine in the next episode. So this rivalry between Hamilton and Jefferson gives rise to what historians call the first party system. So it's the beginnings, really, in American Party politics. But what the musical does that's so clever, its story is not just a political one, it's a personal one. So you have Hamilton, the forgotten star of American independence, the third. forgotten tax rebel. And he's this sort of noble tragic. He loves fiscal policy, doesn't he?
我知道你的观点，但人们可以在下一集中了解我的观点。所以汉密尔顿和杰斐逊之间的这种竞争导致了历史学家所说的第一政党制度。所以这确实是美国政党政治的开端。但这部音乐剧做得非常聪明的地方在于，它的故事不仅是政治性的，也是个人性的。所以你有汉密尔顿，美国独立运动中被遗忘的明星，第三位被遗忘的税务反叛者。他是一个高尚的悲剧人物。他热爱财政政策，不是吗？
I mean, he's all about banks and money and that kind of thing. Yeah. Should have loved the Bank of England. That's the bank he should have been interested in. Anyway, well, he's sort of Othello. And then you have Burr, Aaron Burr, the man who kills him at the jewel, spoiler alert. And he's the antagonist to the musical. He's jealous.
我的意思是，他满脑子都是银行、金钱之类的事情。是的。他应该会喜欢英格兰银行。那才是他应该感兴趣的银行。总之，他有点像奥赛罗。然后你有伯尔，阿隆·伯尔，那个在决斗中杀死他的人，剧透预警。他是音乐剧中的反派。他嫉妒。
He's scheming. And he's cast very much as Iago, isn't he, to Hamilton's hero. And actually that draws on a long tradition in American writing. So Burr has always been seen, you know, the bloke who pulls the trigger has always been seen as one of American history's great villains. Although there have always been iconoclasts who have said, actually, we've got this the wrong way around. Hamilton is the bad guy. And Burr has been smeared by history. So I don't know if you've read any of Gore Vidal's historical novels about 19th century American politics.
他阴险狡诈。他被塑造成了汉密尔顿这位英雄的伊阿古，不是吗？事实上，这借鉴了美国写作中的一个悠久传统。所以伯尔一直被视为，你知道，那个扣动扳机的人一直被视为美国历史上最伟大的反派之一。尽管一直有偶像破坏者说，实际上，我们把事情搞反了。汉密尔顿才是坏人，而伯尔被历史抹黑了。所以我不知道你是否读过戈尔·维达尔关于19世纪美国政治的历史小说。
They're impenetrable. Oh, God. He wrote a book about Zerasta. Oh, yes, yeah. Which was like wading through very thick treacle. See, I quite enjoyed that. But he wrote one called Burr, where he told the whole story from Burr's perspective. And basically in Gauvidal's book, Burr is the Man of Honor.
它们晦涩难懂。哦，天哪。他写了一本关于……的书。哦，是的。那读起来就像在非常浓的糖浆里跋涉。你看，我挺喜欢的。但他写了一本叫《伯尔》的书，他从伯尔的角度讲述了整个故事。基本上在戈尔·维达尔的书里，伯尔是荣誉之士。
And Hamilton is this sort of duplicitous cheating opportunist. I've had everything about Gauvidal annoying. Do you? Incredibly pleased with himself. Do you know what you're like? God, he's so witty. He's so witty. Ha, ha, ha.
而汉密尔顿是那种两面三刀、投机取巧的人。我对戈尔·维达尔的一切都感到厌烦。是吗？他对自己极其满意。你知道你像谁吗？天哪，他太风趣了。他太风趣了。哈哈。
You're like William F. Buckley who punished him, I think, in an interview or something. I am the William Buckley of Gauvedell criticism. Exactly. And then there are other historians, to be fair, who followed the sort of Gauvedel line. So there's a very recent book on Burr by Nancy Eisenberg, and she argues that basically our view of Burr is completely wrong. Can I just say? I mean, so obviously in this period, all the insults derived from Roman history, which I approve of.
你就像威廉·F·巴克利，我想他在一次采访中惩罚了他。我是戈尔·维达尔批评界的威廉·巴克利。完全正确。公平地说，还有其他历史学家遵循戈尔·维达尔的路线。南希·艾森伯格最近写了一本关于伯尔的书，她认为基本上我们对伯尔的看法是完全错误的。我能说一句吗？我的意思是，显然在这一时期，所有的侮辱都源于罗马历史，我对此表示赞同。
Yeah. And Hamilton calls Burr, Cateline. and Catline is this kind of seedy gangster figure who emerges in the late Republic and goes off to lead an uprising. Yeah, this is very Burr. And basically, as we will see, this is accurate. It happens after Hamilton has been killed. So, you know, I'm team Hamilton on this.
是的。汉密尔顿称伯尔为“喀提林”。喀提林是共和国晚期出现的一种卑劣的黑帮人物，后来去领导了一场起义。是的，这非常像伯尔。基本上，正如我们将看到的，这是准确的。这发生在汉密尔顿被杀之后。所以，你知道，在这件事上我是汉密尔顿阵营的。
I think Burr's a terrible man. We'll get a bit deeper into the Hamilton-Bur issue, and you can see if you change your view of Burr. Frankly, I don't think you will, but I'll give it my best shot. So let's start actually with Hamilton. So Hamilton is the man on the $10 bill. And in the opening scene of the musical, the opening number, the song is called Alexander Hamilton. And the lines go like this.
我认为伯尔是个可怕的人。我们将更深入地探讨汉密尔顿与伯尔的问题，看看你是否会改变对伯尔的看法。坦率地说，我不认为你会，但我会尽我所能。那么让我们从汉密尔顿开始吧。汉密尔顿是10美元纸币上的人。在音乐剧的开场场景中，开场曲目叫《亚历山大·汉密尔顿》。歌词是这样的。
How does a bastard orphan, son of a whore and a Scotsman, dropped in the middle of a forgotten spot in the Caribbean by Providence, impoverished in squalor, go up to be a hero and a scholar. Nice rapping, Dominic. In the musical, that is sung by Burr, isn't it? And it's the conceit of the musical that Burr and Hamilton are kind of great mates when they're young. That is not true, is it? No, no, not true at all.
“一个私生子孤儿，一个妓女和苏格兰人的儿子，被天意扔在加勒比海一个被遗忘的角落，在贫困和肮脏中，如何成长为英雄和学者。”说唱得不错，多米尼克。在音乐剧中，那是伯尔唱的，对吧？音乐剧的构思是伯尔和汉密尔顿年轻时是好朋友。那不是真的，对吧？不，不，一点也不真实。
Anyway, the answer to the question is, Hamilton got ahead through ambition, through talent, through hard work, and through good luck. So he's born, we don't know exactly when he was born, because of the circumstances in which he was born. He was probably born in 1755 on the island of Nevis, which is one of the very lucrative sugar islands of the Caribbean, part of the British American Holdings. His father came from Ayrshire, who was called James Hamilton,
总之，这个问题的答案是，汉密尔顿通过野心、天赋、努力工作和好运取得了成功。他出生时，我们不知道他确切的出生日期，因为他出生的环境。他可能出生于1755年的尼维斯岛，那是加勒比海非常赚钱的糖岛之一，属于英属美国领地。他的父亲来自艾尔郡，名叫詹姆斯·汉密尔顿，
and his mother, Rachel Fawcett. the name that Americans give their taps. So she was a Huguenot. James and Rachel were not married. And James ran off when Alexander was very small. So that was the end of James. Alexander grows up. He's a very bookish boy.
他的母亲是瑞秋·福塞特。这是美国人给水龙头的名字。所以她是一个胡格诺派教徒。詹姆斯和瑞秋没有结婚。当亚历山大很小的时候，詹姆斯就跑了。所以詹姆斯的故事就结束了。亚历山大长大了。他是一个非常爱读书的男孩。
He's a big fan of Plutarch and Machiavelli. I mean, Maciabelle, so Plutarch is boilerplate founding father classicism. Machiavelli is slightly more interesting, isn't it? Do you know what? I think Hamilton is slightly more interesting than a lot of the founding fathers? John Adams was a big fan of Machiavelli as well. Yeah.
他是普鲁塔克和马基雅维利的忠实粉丝。我的意思是，马基雅维利，所以普鲁塔克是开国元勋古典主义的样板。马基雅维利稍微有趣一点，不是吗？你知道吗？我认为汉密尔顿比许多开国元勋稍微有趣一点。约翰·亚当斯也是马基雅维利的忠实粉丝。是的。
Oh, was he? Yeah. Paul Giamatti. We haven't done John Adams on this. We should do, John, because you love that series. I do love that series, yeah. In which your wife fell asleep and my wife refused to watch it. Anyway.
哦，是吗？是的。保罗·吉亚玛提。我们还没做过约翰·亚当斯的节目。我们应该做，约翰，因为你喜欢那个系列。我确实喜欢那个系列，是的。在那个系列里，你妻子睡着了，而我妻子拒绝看。总之。
It might be a slightly boy-oriented series. So Hamilton, his mother died when Rachel, when he was in his early teens, which is a bad blow. But he was basically adopted by a local merchant. And the people of Nevis recognised that Hamilton was very bright. And they sent him to the mainland, to North America, for his education. and he ended up in New York. This point, it was the mid-1770s, and as might be expected,
那可能是一个稍微偏向男性的系列。所以汉密尔顿，他的母亲在他十几岁时去世了，这是一个沉重的打击。但他基本上被当地的一位商人收养了。尼维斯的人民认识到汉密尔顿非常聪明。他们把他送到大陆，送到北美接受教育。他最终来到了纽约。此时，那是1770年代中期，正如人们所预料的那样，
with a kind of idealistic, clever young man trying to make something of himself. He sides with his anointed king. No, sadly. He makes a poor choice. He becomes intoxicated with this tax dodging with rebellion and treason. Rebellion and treason.
一个试图有所作为的理想主义、聪明的年轻人。他站在他受膏的国王一边。不，可悲的是。他做出了一个糟糕的选择。他沉迷于这种逃税、叛乱和叛国行为。叛乱和叛国。
He writes a lot of pamphlets attacking his mother country, and then he joined the Continental Army, and he was basically talent-spotted to become the chief staff aide to George Washington of Teeth fame. And Hamilton sees action at some of these, I think Americans like to call them battles, but we called them basically brawls in fields,
他写了许多攻击母国的小册子，然后他加入了大陆军，他基本上被发掘成为乔治·华盛顿（以牙齿闻名）的首席参谋。汉密尔顿在其中一些战斗中看到了行动，我想美国人喜欢称它们为战斗，但我们称它们基本上是田野里的斗殴，
Trenton and Princeton and Yorktown. But he has this quite complicated relationship with Washington because Hamilton is very much as protégé, and they're close. There's a sense especially as the war, you know, in the later years of the war, the Hamilton is always kind of itching for more. Basically, Hamilton wants to see his own,
特伦顿、普林斯顿和约克镇。但他与华盛顿的关系相当复杂，因为汉密尔顿很大程度上是他的门生，他们很亲近。有一种感觉，特别是在战争后期，汉密尔顿总是渴望更多。基本上，汉密尔顿希望看到自己的名字和华盛顿的一样闪耀。这有俄狄浦斯情结。我想有一点。汉密尔顿和伯尔，决定性的特征之一，就是这种燃烧的野心，可能是因为读了太多的普鲁塔克。你知道，他们想在自己的伟大生活书中占有一席之地。所以基本上做华盛顿的随从对他来说是不够的。我认为这让你对他的个性有了一些了解。
name in lights as well as Washington's. There's sets of Edipal. I think a little bit. Both Hamilton and Burr, one of the defining characteristics, is this burning ambition, probably fueled by reading too much Plutarch. You know, they want to be in a book of great lives of their own. And so basically being Washington's, you know, bag carrier is not enough for him. And I think that gives you a sense of his personality.
他非常聪明。他非常有活力。他是一位出色的作家。你知道，他身上有很多值得钦佩的地方。然而，每个人都说的一件事是，汉密尔顿说话非常尖刻。他非常傲慢，非常尖酸刻薄。他在整个职业生涯中都有疏远他人并将潜在盟友变成敌人的本领。耶鲁大学历史学家乔安妮·弗里曼这样评价他：
He's very clever. He's very energetic. He's a brilliant writer. You know, there's lots of admirable things about him. The one thing everyone says, though, is that he's very sharp-tongued Hamilton. He's very arrogant and he's very acerbic. He has a knack throughout his career of alienating people and of turning potential allies into enemies. And the Yale historian Joanne Freeman says of him,
他在政治上太极端，太冲动，太不愿忍受愚蠢，太确信自己总是对的，太警惕民主的运作和街头政治，以至于无法真正适应1790年代的政治。所以虽然他做得很好，当然他也成为了财政部长，但他会成为总统吗？可能不会，因为有太多人就是不喜欢他。他只是惹恼了他们。
he was too extreme in his politics, too impulsive, too unwilling to suffer fools, too convinced he was always right and too wary of the workings of democracy and the politics of the street to really give. get on in the politics of the 1790s. So although he does very well, and of course he becomes Treasury Secretary, would he ever have become president? Probably not because there were too many people who just don't like him. And he's just rubbed them up the wrong way.
总之，我扯远了。他真正将自己的名字载入史册是在战争之后。因为他是导致1789年宪法通过的辩论中的重要人物。然后他撰写了《联邦党人文集》中的大部分文章，解释了宪法背后的思想。我想所有美国人在学校时都被迫阅读其中的一些文章，并发现它们极其无聊。
Anyway, I'm jumping ahead. It's really after the war that he writes his name into the history books. Because it's a big figure in the debates that leads the adoption of the Constitution, 1789. And then he writes the majority of the essays in the Federalist papers that explain the thinking behind the Constitution. and I think all Americans are forced to read some of these papers when they're at school and find them incredibly boring.
美国人通常讨厌汉密尔顿吗？你肯定会，不是吗？我的意思是，事情就是这样运作的。你长大后，就像那些学习A-level英语的人最终讨厌弥尔顿一样。所以，1789年秋天，华盛顿是第一任总统，他让他的老助手担任他的第一任财政部长。这就是汉密尔顿真正将自己的名字烙印在美国政治意识中的地方。基本上，在1790年代，他们有了这个新国家，他们无法决定它将成为什么样的国家。13个州，它们都有债务，不是吗？
Do Americans generally hate Hamilton? Surely you would, wouldn't you? I mean, it's the way that these things work. That you grow up, it's like people who do A-level English end up hating Milton. So, autumn, 1789, Washington is the first president, and he gets his old aide to be his first Treasury Secretary. And this is where Hamilton really kind of, his name is seared into the American political consciousness. Basically, in the 1790s, they've got this new.
是的，它们都有债务。这13个州非常不同。它们并不一定都同意彼此的观点。它们是否真的会永远留在它们的新国家里是非常不清楚的。现在，有些人说新的美国基本上应该是一个非常松散的邦联。
country and they can't decide what kind of country it's going to be. 13 states and they've all got debts, haven't they? Yeah, they've all got debts. And the 13 states are quite different. They don't all necessarily agree with each other. And whether they will actually stay in their new country forever is very unclear. Now, there are some people who say the new United States should basically be a very loose confederation.
我们应该有一个非常有限的中央政府。我的意思是，中央政府基本上不应该真正存在。我们是一个农村国家。我们是一个由农民和种植园组成的农业国家。而说这些话的人通常居住在弗吉尼亚州和卡罗来纳州等南部州。杰斐逊是他们伟大的代言人。然后你有来自东北部的人。所以来自波士顿和纽约等城市的人。
We should have a very limited central government. I mean, the central government basically shouldn't really exist at all. We are a rural country. We are an agrarian country of kind of farmers and plantations. And the people who are saying this often live in southern states like Virginia and the Carolinas. And Jefferson is their great spokesman. And then you have people especially from the northeast. So people from the cities of Boston and New York.
他们说，不，那根本不是你想要的国家。我们应该有一个更具凝聚力的国家。我们需要一个强大的政府来团结我们。好吧，让我们拥有一个充满活力的联邦政府。让我们考虑与英国的贸易、制造业和商业以及所有这些事情。这使得他们在南方批评者眼中显得既过于亲英又过于君主制。这就是批评。是的，完全正确。
And they say, no, that's not the sort of country you want at all. We should have a much more cohesive country. We need a strong government that unites us. Well, let's have a dynamic federal government. Let us think about trade and manufacturing and commerce with Great Britain and all these things. And this makes them seem to their southern critics, both overly pro-British and overly monarchist. That's the criticism. Yes, exactly.
这很有趣。他们说他们太英国化了。他们基本上想以另一个名字把君主制带回来。他们关心的只是资产负债表。现在，汉密尔顿非常倾向于东北部的观点。他想要一个强大的中央政府，一个强大的行政部门。他想要对制造业的援助。他想要一个国家银行。
And it's interesting. They say they're too British. They're basically want to bring the monarchy back under another name. And all they care about is the balance sheet. Now, Hamilton is very much of the northeastern persuasion. He wants a strong central government, a strong executive. He wants aid to manufacturing. He wants a national bank.
所以这家银行将承担各州的债务。它将向联邦政府借钱。它将改善美国在国外的信誉。他说，让我们和英国人做朋友吧。毕竟，他们是我们天然的盟友。而最糟糕的人，实际上是法国人，因为他们经历了革命，那是混乱、无序和所有这一切。
So this bank would assume the debts of the states. It would lend money to the federal government. It would improve America's credit abroad. He says, let's be pals with the British. They're our natural allies, after all. And the worst people, actually, are the French, because they've had the revolution, and that's disorder and it's chaos and all of this.
显然，正如你所说，其他人认为这家伙基本上，你知道，他是一个……进行革命到底有什么意义？他只是想把英国人带回来。而这些人的拥护者，汉密尔顿的批评者，正如你所说，是托马斯·杰斐逊。我们将在周四更多地讨论他。所以在华盛顿的第一个任期内，这种争论开始演变成可以识别的政党政治。所以在1792年，你有了第一次属于政党路线的国会选举。杰斐逊的政党自称为民主共和党人，这对于考虑当今政治的人来说有点令人困惑。而汉密尔顿的政党，
And obviously, the other people, as you said, this bloke is just basically, you know, he's a, what was the point in having the revolution at all? He just wants to bring the British back. And the champion of these people, Hamilton's critics, is, as you say, Thomas Jefferson. And we'll talk about him more on Thursday. So during Washington's first term, this argument begins to turn to something recognizable as party politics. So in 1792, you have the first congressional elections that fall under kind of party lines. Jefferson's party called themselves the Democratic Republicans, which is slightly confusing for people who think about politics today. And Hamilton's party,
政党被称为联邦党人。乔治·华盛顿，他置身事外。他认为自己的角色是立宪君主。而且，他不能说话，对吧？因为他露出牙齿。他只是坐在那里。谁知道呢？谁知道呢？谁知道他在想什么？如果他真的在想什么的话。所以，他什么也没说。正因为如此，这对新共和国非常有用。它运作得非常好。他在1792年毫无争议地连任。但在1796年，也就是四年后，华盛顿卸任，你知道，确立了总统两任的先例。并且有一场真正的竞争来接替他。约翰·亚当斯，温和的联邦党人，他与……我差点用了英国西南部口音，
party are called the Federalists. George Washington, he stays above it. He sees his role as being that of a constitutional monarch. Also, he can't talk, can he? Because he show his teeth. He just sits there. Who knows? Who knows? Who knows? Who knows what he thinks? If he thinks anything at all. So, he says nothing. And because of this, this is very useful for the new republic. It works very well. he is re-elected unopposed in 1792. But in 1796, so four years later, Washington steps down, you know, establishes the two-term precedent. And there's a proper contest to replace him. And John Adams, moderate federalist, he runs against, I verged on the West Country voice,
他们是约翰·亚当斯，只是一个约翰·亚当斯。他与托马斯·杰斐逊竞争，他击败了他。所以约翰·亚当斯上台了，他是一个温和的联邦党人，正如我所说。他度过了一段糟糕的时光。他作为总统度过了一段可怕的时光。好吧，他让美国远离了战争，不是吗？在英国和法国之间，这是他伟大的成就，但这以他的声誉为巨大代价。他是那种基本上，你知道，你在政治中经常看到的人，
they were John Adams, just a John Adams. He runs against Thomas Jefferson, and he beats him. So John Adams is in, and he's a kind of moderate federalist, as I said. and he has a terrible time. He has an awful time as president. Well, he keeps America out of the war, doesn't he, between Britain and France, which is his great achievement, but it comes at massive cost to his reputation. He's one of these people who basically, you know, you see it so often in politics,
他试图保持中间立场，有点像自由民主党人，每个人都说，啊，他没用，他是个软骨头，他什么都不代表。我的意思是，对他批评的一部分正是他有成为君主主义者的抱负。我的意思是，他和杰斐逊曾经是好朋友。他们一起在法国，并因此彻底决裂。他们确实决裂了。但亚当斯的悲剧在于联邦党人也鄙视他。所以汉密尔顿和联邦党人说，啊，他很软弱。
he tries to hold the middle ground, it's a bit of a Lib Dem, and everyone says, ah, he's uses, he's a wishy-washy, he doesn't stand for anything. I mean, part of the criticism of him is precisely that he has aspirations to be a monarchist. I mean, this is, he and Jefferson were great pals. They'd been in France together, and they completely break up over it. They do. But the tragedy for Adams is the Federalists don't despise him as well. So Hamilton and Federalists say, are, he's weak.
他不够联邦党人。所以你到了1800年，杰斐逊又要参选了。这确实是杰斐逊志在必得的选举。每个人都认为杰斐逊会赢。现在，我们下次会说更多，所以我不想在杰斐逊那一集中踩你的脚趾，汤姆。但基本上发生的事情是民主共和党人确实赢得了总统选举，正如预期的那样。但由于非常复杂的原因，我们不需要深入探讨。
He's not enough of a Federalist. So you get to 1800 and Jefferson's going to run again. And this really is Jefferson's election to win. Everyone thinks Jefferson's going to win. Now, we'll say more about this next time, so I don't want to tread on your toes, Tom, for the Jefferson episode. But basically what happens is the Democratic Republic. do win the presidential election as expected. But for very complicated reasons, which we don't need to go into it.
非常复杂的原因。选举人团出现了平局。所以基本上，民主共和党选举人，这些选举人团的成员，必须从他们投票的联合名单中选择总统。当人们计算所有选票时，杰斐逊和他的竞选搭档在总统职位上以各73票打平。
Very complicated reasons. There is a tie in the Electoral College. So basically, the Democratic Republican electors, the members of this electoral college, have to choose the president from the joint ticket on which they've kind of voted. And when people count all the votes, Jefferson and his running mate are tied for the presidency on 73 votes each. and one of them's clearly going to be president and one of them's going to be vice president, but it's going to fall to the House of Representatives
其中一人显然将成为总统，另一人将成为副总统，但将由众议院来决定谁是谁。而众议院此时由汉密尔顿的联邦党控制。他们必须决定他们想要托马斯·杰斐逊担任总统还是他的竞选搭档，一个叫阿隆·伯尔的人。这把我们带到了伯尔，我认为他是美国历史上最迷人的，
to choose which is which. And the House of Representatives is controlled at this point by Hamilton's Federalist Party. And they have to decide they want to have Thomas Jefferson as president or his running mate, who is a man called Aaron Burr. And this brings us to Burr, who is, I think, one of the most fascinating,
迷人且模棱两可的人物之一。我认为伯尔身上有一点尼克松式的色彩。一种阴郁的、讽刺的智慧。他出生于新泽西州，1756年。他也成了孤儿。他在两岁时就成了孤儿。他去和一个虐待他的叔叔住在一起。他去了普林斯顿。
Fascinating and ambiguous characters in American history. There's something slightly Nixonian about Burr, I think. A sort of brooding, sort of sardonic intellect. He's born in New Jersey, 1756. He too was orphaned. He was orphaned at the age of two. He went to live with an abusive uncle. He went to Princeton.
我刚才说了，多米尼克，他是为18世纪美国神学爱好者准备的，我知道外面有很多这样的人。他是乔纳森·爱德华兹的孙子，就像大觉醒运动中的那样。是的。但他学习神学。他对此很感兴趣。好吧，乔纳森·爱德华兹，我想知道他对他随后的决斗生涯会怎么看。我不认为他会赞同。
I just said, Dominic, he's for fans of 18th century American theology, which I know there are lots out there. He's the grandson of Jonathan Edwards, as in the Great Awakening. Yeah. But he studied theology. He was interested in it. Well, Jonathan Edwards, make of his subsequent dueling career, I wonder. I don't think you'd approve at all.
不，我不认为你会。不，那绝对是一个污点。是的，绝对是。所以伯尔在1775年加入了大陆军。他英勇作战。他参加了我们第一集提到的福吉谷。所以跪在雪地里。跪在雪地里，他在那里指挥一个连队，打板球，当然，
No, I don't think you would. No, that's a definite black mark. Yeah, definitely. So Burr enlisted in the Continental Army in 1775. He fought with great courage. He was at Valley Forge from our first episode. So kneeling in the snow. Nealing in the snow, he commanded a company there, playing cricket, surely,
而且脚上穿着破布之类的东西，吃着那些火饼什么的。他是一个严格的纪律执行者。他在福吉谷平息了一场兵变。每个人都说他打了一场好仗。战后，他成为纽约一位非常成功的律师和政治家。1780年代和1790年代的纽约政治非常、非常激烈。伯尔站在杰斐逊一边，而不是汉密尔顿一边。他基本上把纽约交给了杰斐逊。完全正确。伯尔和汉密尔顿，他们的宿怨，我认为始于1791年。这是汉密尔顿的岳父菲利普·斯凯勒
and also wearing rags on his feet and stuff and eating those fire cakes or whatever they were called. And he was a strict disciplinarian. He faced down a mutiny at Valley Forge. Forge. Everyone said he had a good war. After the war, he became a very successful lawyer and politician in New York. New York in 1780s and 1790s got very, very fierce, factional politics. And Burr takes Jefferson's side and not Hamilton's. He basically delivers New York to Jefferson. Exactly so. And Burr and Hamilton, really their feud, I think, began in 1791. And this is when Hamilton's father-in-law, Philip Schuyler, was
竞选连任纽约参议员时，伯尔击败了他。所以从那时起，就有了不和。但这远不止是汉密尔顿和杰斐逊之间的不和。我认为部分原因是，如果汉密尔顿——我现在要用英国习语来激怒我们的美国听众——如果汉密尔顿是马麦酱（Marmite），伯尔非常像牛肉膏（Bovril）。那是什么意思？这意味着，你知道，人们要么爱要么恨马麦酱。是的，人们要么爱要么恨马麦酱。
running for re-election, a senator from New York, and Burr beat him. And so from that point onwards, there's a bit of bad blood. But this is far more than the bad blood between Hamilton and Jefferson. And I think part of this is because if Hamilton, I'm going to irritate our American listeners by using British idiom now, if Hamilton is Marmite, Burr is very much Bovril. What does that mean? It means that basically, you know, people love or loathe marmite. Yeah, and people love or hate marmite.
但牛肉膏更具争议性，不是吗？不。不。错了。我从来没见过不喜欢牛肉膏的人。我会告诉你谁现在在取消订阅。素食主义者和纯素食主义者。他们仍然喜欢它。
But Bofferel is even more divisive, no? No. No. Wrong. I've never met anyone who doesn't love Bovril. I'll tell you who's cancelling their subscriptions now. Vegetarians and vegans. They still love it.
他们不喜欢。他们可能喜欢它的概念，而不是现实。就像，你知道，你喜欢培根，但你不吃它。我不认为纯素食主义是这样运作的。好吧。好的。伯尔就像他的孤儿同伴汉密尔顿一样。他非常聪明。
They don't. They might like the idea of it, but not the reality. It's like, you know, you love bacon, but you don't eat it. I don't think that's how veganism works. Right. Okay. Burr is like his fellow orphan Hamilton. He's very clever.
他非常有野心。他工作努力。他非常尖刻。他对朋友很慷慨。在某些方面，他相当进步，按现代标准来看。所以他非常批评奴隶制。他反对本土主义，他赞成妇女投票权。所以他非常超前于他的时代。他还有一个名字很奇怪的妻子和女儿，不是吗？西奥多西亚。她们都叫西奥多西亚。
He's very ambitious. He's hardworking. He's very acerbic. He's generous to his friends. In some ways, he's quite. progressive by modern standards. So he's very critical of slavery. He is opposed to nativism, and he favours votes for women. So he's very ahead of his time. He also has very gruevily named wife and daughter, doesn't he? Theodosia. They're both called Theodosia.
是的，尽管他不是世界上最忠诚的丈夫。所以我认为伯尔是个花花公子。他基本上是个性瘾者。所以据说他经常光顾纽约所有20家最高档的妓院，而这些女性显然认为伯尔是她们最好的顾客。总之，伯尔，他非常狡猾，自私自利。我认为关于他的一点是，他除了阿隆·伯尔之外，并不真正代表任何东西。所以难怪你喜欢他。是的，完全正确。汉密尔顿非常固执。
Yes, although he's not the most loyal husband in the world. So I think Burr was such a philandre. He's basically a sex addict. So he was said to have frequented all 20 of the finest prostitutes in New York. and these women apparently were of the view that Burr was their finest customer. Anyway, Burr is, he's very wily, he's self-interested. And I think the thing about him is, he doesn't really stand for anything other than Aaron Burr. So no wonder you like him. Yeah, exactly. Hamilton is very stubborn.
而且，你知道，他是一个有固定原则的人。伯尔是多变的。伯尔会不惜一切代价取得成功。所以在一个人们基本上在扮演小加图的时代，伯尔脱颖而出。他是喀提林。是的，好吧，就是这样。非常多变。
And, you know, he's a man of fixed principles. Burr is changeable. Burr will do whatever it takes to get ahead. So in an age when people are basically cosplaying as Cato the Younger, Burr stands out. He is Catalan. Yeah, well, there you go. Very changeable.
所以，让我们回到1800年。伯尔，正如你所说，是杰斐逊的二号人物。所以选举人团陷入了僵局。现在，有些人可能会说，好吧，我显然总是要成为竞选搭档，所以我只要对每个人说，好吧，投票给杰斐逊。你知道，我会做二号人物。伯尔想，不，这是我成为一号人物的机会。如果我现在向联邦党人献媚，
So, let's get back to the year 1800. Burr, as you said, is Jefferson's number two. So the electoral college is deadlocked. Now, some people might say, well, I was obviously always going to be the running mate, so I shall just say to everybody, well, vote for Jefferson. You know, I'll be the number two. Burr thinks, no, this is my chance to be the number one. If I suck up now to the Federalists,
他们会选择我作为两害相权取其轻，我就会成为总统。然而，伯尔的问题是，汉密尔顿对他产生了深深的厌恶。在1801年的整个冬天，汉密尔顿告诉他所有的朋友，看，我知道我们不是杰斐逊的粉丝，但我们必须不惜一切代价阻止这个叫伯尔的家伙。所以这是一封1800年12月的信。杰斐逊不是那么危险的家伙。但至于伯尔，他没有任何优点。
they will pick me as the lesser of two evils, and I will be president. The problem for Burr, though, Hamilton has taken a deep dislike to him. And through the winter of 1801, Hamilton tells all his friends, look, I know we're not Jefferson fans, but we have to stop this bloke Burr at all costs. So this is a letter from December 1800. Jefferson is not so dangerous, sir Mann. But as to Burr, there is nothing in his favour.
他除了掠夺国家之外，已经破产到无可救药。他的公共原则除了他自己的扩张之外没有其他源头。然后是另一封信，1801年1月，几周后，汉密尔顿对一位朋友说，伯尔是一个放荡者、破产者、极端的享乐主义者。没有人能说出他的政治原则是什么。他在指南针周围谈论了一切。有时他处理雅各宾主义的所有术语。
He is bankrupt beyond redemption except by the plunder of his country. His public principles have no other spring than his own aggrandized. And then another letter, January 1801, a few weeks later, Hamilton says to a friend, Burr is a profligate, a bankrupt, a voluptuary in the extreme. No mortal can tell what his political principles are. He's talked all around the compass. At times he's dealt in all the jargon of Jacobinism.
有时他断然宣称联邦政府完全不足，必须改变为一个更有活力的政府。事实似乎是，他，指伯尔，除了通过任何手段获得权力并以一切手段保持权力之外，没有其他计划。他会讨好并利用每个政党中能干且大胆的恶棍，通过利用他们的帮助和社会的各种坏情绪，他很可能会尝试篡权。所以他是后革命时代美国的安迪·伯纳姆。
At other times he's proclaimed decidedly the total insufficiency of the federal government and the necessity of changes to one far more energetic. The truth seems to be that he, meaning Burr, has no plan but that of getting power by any means and keeping it by all means. He will court and employ able and daring scoundrels of every party, and by availing himself of their assistance and of all the bad passions of society, he will in all likelihood attempt a usurpation. So he is the Andy Burnham of post-revolutionary America.
这个比较太好了。安迪·伯纳姆没有固定的原则，不是吗？他只是编造，说任何他认为人们想听的话。他会说任何东西，我会眨眨眼，对吧？穿上一件防风衣。所以这非常符合伯尔的氛围。总之，汉密尔顿反对他。经过36轮投票，众议院选择了杰斐逊。
That is such a good comparison. Andy Burnham has no fixed principles, does he? He just kind of makes up, say whatever he thinks people want. He'd just say any stuff and I'd flutter his eyelashes, right? And put on an an anorack. So this is very much Burr's vibe. Anyway, Hamilton's campaigned against him. After 36 ballots, the House of Representatives chooses Jefferson.
伯尔被掏空了。他把这归咎于汉密尔顿。他说，汉密尔顿密谋反对我。我的意思是，他没说错。很久以后，他对一位朋友说，他说，我曾想挑战汉密尔顿决斗，但他通过自愿站出来道歉而抢先了我。出于对他的体贴和对和平的真诚渴望，
And Burr is gutted. And he blames Hamilton for this. He says, Hamilton intrigued against me. I mean, he's not wrong. And much later, he said to a friend, he said, I was tempted to challenge Hamilton to a duel, but he anticipated me by voluntarily coming forward and making apologies. from delicacy to him and from a sincere desire for peace,
我从未提及这些情况，总是希望我的慷慨行为能对他产生一些影响。那不是很美好吗？这是否属实，是不可能说的。汉密尔顿真的去向他道歉了吗？我认为这极不可能。伯尔有撒谎的记录吗？
I have never mentioned these circumstances, always hoping that the generosity of my conduct would have some influence on his. Isn't that nice? Whether actually this is true, it's impossible to say. Did Hamilton really come and apologise to him? I think it's highly unlikely. Does Burr have a track record as telling fibs?
是的，我想也许有夸大其词。让我们转到1804年。伯尔已经成为副总统。杰斐逊当然现在不信任他，因为他知道伯尔基本上试图抢夺最高职位。所以他把伯尔边缘化了，当他在1804年竞选连任时，他计划把伯尔从名单中剔除。所以伯尔需要一份新工作，他决定在纽约找一份。那年春天，1804年，他竞选纽约州州长。现在，虽然从技术上讲他仍然是民主共和党人，
Yes, tall stories, I think maybe. Let's move on to 1804. Burr has become vice president. Jefferson, of course, doesn't trust him now because he knows that Per basically tried to snatch the top job. So he's sidelined Burr, and when he runs for re-election in 1804, he's planning to drop Burr from the ticket. So Burr needs a new job, and he decides to get one back in New York. And that spring, 1804, he makes a bid for the New York governorship. Now, although technically he's still a Democratic Republican,
因为他多变的本性，也因为他在民主共和党人那里留下了污点。他决定以联邦党人的拥护者身份参选。这是一场非常激烈的竞选，即使伯尔现在已经改换门庭，汉密尔顿仍然反对他。部分原因是个人原因，但汉密尔顿也确实担心伯尔，他真诚地认为伯尔是对联邦生存的威胁。我们很容易忘记，在19世纪初，共和国仍然感觉非常脆弱。杰斐逊派和汉密尔顿派之间的分歧非常深。新英格兰有很多汉密尔顿派、联邦党人，他们有点喜欢分裂的想法，试图分裂。为什么我们要和一个国家里所有这些来自
because of his changeable nature and because he's blotted his copybook with the Democratic Republic, Republicans. He decides he will run as the champion of the federalists. There's a very bitter campaign and even though Burr has now changed his coat, Hamilton is still opposed to him. And part of this is personal, but also Hamilton is actually worried that Burr, he genuinely thinks Burr is a threat to the survival of the Union. It's easy for us to forget that in the early 1800s, the Republic still feels very fragile. The division between Jeffersonians and Hamiltonians, runs very deep. And there's a lot of Hamiltonians, federalists in New England, who kind of like the idea of breaking away, attempted to break away. Why are we in a country with all these people
弗吉尼亚州的人在一起，他们整天唠叨着耕种？让我们摆脱他们，自己单干吧。事实上，在1804年初，有一个非常、非常初步的、某种分裂阴谋，集中在华盛顿的老国务卿蒂莫西·皮克林身上。汉密尔顿发现了这一点，他说，哦，这太可怕了。不要这样做。不惜一切代价保持联邦团结。另一方面，伯尔似乎发出了信号。我对此持开放态度。
from Virginia who are just wittering on about farming all the time? Let's get rid of them, go off on our own. And there's actually in early 1804 a very, very tentative, sort of separatist plot that is focused on Washington's old secretary of state man called Timothy Pickering. and Hamilton finds out about this and he says, oh, this is terrible. Don't do this. Keep the union together at all costs. Burr, on the other hand, seems to have sent signals. I could be open to this.
你知道，这可能有一点好处。如果我成为纽约州州长，如果你帮我成为纽约州州长，我将非常有兴趣和你更多地谈谈这个伟大的项目。如果球在灌木丛后面松动了怎么办？完全正确。汉密尔顿对这些人说，伯尔是一条蛇。不要相信伯尔，不要投票给伯尔，所有这些。好吧，他没说错，不是吗？
You know, there could be a little mileage in this. If I become governor of New York, if you help me become governor of New York, I would very much be interested in talking to you more about this excellent project. Should the ball come loose at the back of the scrub? Exactly. And Hamilton says to these people, Burr is a snake. Don't trust Burr, don't vote for Burr, all of this. Well, he's not wrong, is he?
他有点像条蛇。或者他只是一个非常精明的现代政治家？不，他是一条蛇。好吧，结果是伯尔的民主共和党对手以压倒性优势获胜，那个人叫摩根·刘易斯，你知道，相当默默无闻。伯尔再次受到羞辱。当然，他把这归咎于汉密尔顿。然后，在选举七周后，伯尔被展示了一份旧报纸，1804年4月24日的《奥尔巴尼纪事报》。
He's a bit of a snake. Or is he just a very adept, modern politician? No, he's a snake. Well, the result is a landslide victory for the Democratic Republican opponent to Burr, who's a bloke called Morgan Lewis, who, you know, quite obscure. Burr has been humiliated yet again. And of course, he blames Hamilton. And then, seven weeks after the election, Burr has shown an old newspaper, the Albany Register from the 24th of April 1804.
他有点像条毒蛇。又或者他只是一个非常精明、现代的政客？不，他就是条毒蛇。好吧，结果是伯尔的民主共和党对手摩根·刘易斯以压倒性优势获胜，他是个名不见经传的人。伯尔再次蒙受羞辱。当然，他把责任归咎于汉密尔顿。然后，在选举七周后，有人给伯尔看了一份旧报纸，即1804年4月24日的《奥尔巴尼纪事报》。
And this was the day that voting opened in the election. And the paper had printed a letter from a man called Dr. Charles D. Cooper, opposing Burr's candidacy. And Cooper said in the letter, he said, I've heard Hamilton talking about Burr. I heard Hamilton say that he, and I quote, he looked upon Mr. Burr to be a dangerous man and one who ought not to be trusted with the reins of government. And Cooper goes on to say, if you put him,
这一天正是选举投票开始的日子。报纸刊登了一封来自查尔斯·D·库珀博士的信，信中反对伯尔的候选人资格。库珀在信中写道，他说，我曾听汉密尔顿谈论过伯尔。我听汉密尔顿说，他——引用他的原话——他认为伯尔先生是一个危险人物，一个不应该被委以政府重任的人。库珀接着说，如果你让他，
pushed me, and I quote, I could detail to you a still more despicable opinion which General Hamilton has expressed of Mr. Burr. Burr reads this and he's absolutely furious. And a few days after he's read it on the 18th of June, his great pal, a man named William Van Ness, delivers a letter to Hamilton. Burr says, I'm absolutely outraged by this word in particular, despicable. I want a prompt and unqualified acknowledgement or denial that you ever use this word despicable about me. See, I find this quite odd, because surely in the rough and tumble of politics, people are allowed to insult their opponents, aren't they?
推了我一把，引用原话，我可以向你详细说明汉密尔顿将军对伯尔先生表达的更为卑劣的看法。伯尔读到这些话时，感到极其愤怒。在读到这封信的几天后，即6月18日，他的一位挚友，名叫威廉·范内斯的人，将一封信送交给了汉密尔顿。伯尔说，我对这个词，特别是“卑劣”这个词感到无比愤慨。我要求你立即且无条件地承认或否认你曾经用“卑劣”这个词来形容我。你看，我觉得这很奇怪，因为在政治的激烈竞争中，人们难道不应该被允许侮辱他们的对手吗？
Yeah, you would think so. Was he just looking for a reason to get into a punch-up with him? I think possibly, although the idea of honour matters enormously to American politicians in this period. So jewelly is not uncommon at all, and the punch-ups of this kind are not uncommon. But I think ultimately you're right that Burr is looking for a pretext to challenge Hamilton for reasons that maybe we'll get into. I think it's a way for him to, he sees it as a way to rebuild his credibility.
是的，你可能会这么想。他是不是只是在找借口和对方打一架？我想有可能，尽管荣誉的概念在这一时期的美国政客心中极其重要。所以决斗一点也不罕见，这种打斗也并不罕见。但我认为你最终是对的，伯尔是在寻找挑战汉密尔顿的借口，原因我们稍后可能会谈到。我认为这对他来说是一种方式，他将其视为重建自己信誉的一种途径。
Anyway, Hamilton sent his answer two days later. And Hamilton's answer is extremely long and convoluted. It's hard to tell whether he's, A, massively overthinking it, or B, he's basically just making fun of Burr. So he starts by saying, he says, well, the word despicable. admits of infinite shades from the very light to the very dark. How am I to judge of the degree intended? And then he goes on to say,
总之，汉密尔顿两天后发出了回复。汉密尔顿的回复极其冗长且晦涩。很难判断他到底是：A，想得太多了；还是B，他基本上就是在戏弄伯尔。所以他开头说，他说，嗯，“卑劣”这个词，包含着从极轻到极重的无数种含义。我该如何判断你所指的程度呢？然后他接着说，
I don't remember using that word to this bloke, Dr. Cooper, and I refuse on principle to consent to be interrogated as to the justness of inferences which may be drawn from others from whatever I have said of a political opponent in the course of a 15-year competition. Now, people like you, Tom, you see Hamilton very much as the hero of the story. It's a bit of a martyr.
我不记得对这位库珀博士用过那个词，而且我原则上拒绝接受质询，以证明别人从我在长达15年的竞争中对政治对手所说的任何话中推断出的结论是否正确。现在，像你这样的人，汤姆，你非常把汉密尔顿看作这个故事的英雄。有点像个殉道者。
I think that's a great letter. I think it's important to say this is not at all a conciliatory letter. There's something perhaps a little bit pedantic, a little bit smug about Hamilton's letter. No, it's not smug at all. He's been sent a ludicrous letter by a ludicrous baffoon, and he's pricking the pomposity of Burr in a very delicate and engaging way. I think Burr is a bit pompous, but I think Hamilton is goading him. And Hamilton ends, this last bit is definitely goading him. I trust on more reflection, you will see the matter in the same light with me.
我认为那是一封很棒的信。我认为必须说明的是，这绝不是一封和解的信。汉密尔顿的信里或许有一点点迂腐，有一点点自鸣得意。不，一点也不自鸣得意。他收到了一封来自一个滑稽小丑的荒谬信件，他正在以一种非常微妙且引人入胜的方式刺破伯尔的自负。我认为伯尔有点自负，但我认为汉密尔顿是在激怒他。汉密尔顿最后结尾的那一段绝对是在激怒他。我相信经过更多反思，你会和我以同样的眼光看待这件事。
If not, I can only regret the circumstance and must abide the consequences. Well, the next day, Burr writes back again. He says, I've read your letter, and I regret to find none of the sincerity and delicacy which you profess to value. Political opposition can never absolve gentlemen from the necessity of a rigid adherence to the laws of honour and the rules of decorum. Your letter has furnished me with new reasons for acquiring. a definite reply. I mean, to be fair to them, they wrote good letters. They did.
如果不然，我只能对这种情况表示遗憾，并必须承担后果。好吧，第二天，伯尔又写信回复了。他说，我读了你的信，很遗憾我没有发现你自称珍视的任何真诚和细腻。政治上的对立绝不能免除绅士们严格遵守荣誉法和礼仪规则的必要性。你的信为我提供了要求明确答复的新理由。我的意思是，公平地说，他们写出的信确实很好。确实。
I mean, it would have been wonderful if the people criticized by Trump had responded to him in similar term. If Ted Cruz had written Trump a letter like this. Ronda Santis. Yeah. Low energy, Jebush. Brilliant. I'd love to see a duel in which all these men were fighting, frankly.
我的意思是，如果那些受到特朗普批评的人能以同样的措辞回应他，那该多好。如果泰德·克鲁兹给特朗普写了这样一封信。罗恩·德桑蒂斯。是的。低能量的杰布。太精彩了。坦白说，我很想看到这些男人进行一场决斗。
Maybe in that large cage. Yeah, in the cage in the white house. in the White House. They kind of run at each other on motorbikes. They're the final boss is Joe Biden. That would be an unexpected twist. That would be a twist. Right.
也许在那个大笼子里。是的，在白宫的笼子里。在白宫。他们骑着摩托车冲向对方。最后的BOSS是乔·拜登。那将是一个意想不到的转折。那确实会是一个转折。没错。
The 22nd, the next day, Hamilton replies, and it's a much shorter letter. And Hamilton says, look, if you want, by definite reply, you want either the direct avowal or disavowal required in your first letter. I have no other answer to give than that which has already been given. And that's basically that. There's a bit of back and forth now between Burr's mate, Van Ness and Hamilton's friend Nathaniel Pendleton, but in essence this is the story. Burr has asked for an apology.
22日，也就是第二天，汉密尔顿回复了，这是一封短得多的信。汉密尔顿说，听着，如果你想要“明确答复”，你想要你第一封信中要求的直接承认或否认。除了已经给出的答复外，我没有其他答复可给。基本上就是这样。现在伯尔的伙伴范内斯和汉密尔顿的朋友纳撒尼尔·彭德尔顿之间有一些来回，但本质上这就是故事。伯尔要求道歉。
Hamilton has said no, and so this is now a matter of honour, which means a jewel. So we should say a little bit about jewels. Jewels are part of the, they're an essential part really, of the culture of honour among gentlemen in North America in the late 18th, early 19th century. They weren't universally popular. Some of the founding fathers hated jewelling. So Franklin, who you love, he was very anti-jewaling. He said it was a murderous practice.
汉密尔顿拒绝了，所以这现在成了荣誉问题，这意味着决斗。所以我们应该谈谈决斗。决斗是18世纪末19世纪初北美绅士荣誉文化中不可或缺的一部分。它们并不普遍受欢迎。一些开国元勋讨厌决斗。所以你喜欢的富兰克林，他非常反对决斗。他说这是一种谋杀行为。
Well, he's a figure of the Enlightenment. He's not going to put up this nonsense. No, Jefferson doesn't like jewelling. John Adams doesn't like jewelling. But if you've been in the army, you tend to like jewelling. If you're from the south, you're much more likely to like jewelling. I mean, it's very hard to get precise figures for jewels because jewels were, in many states, technically, illegal.
嗯，他是启蒙运动的人物。他不会容忍这种胡闹。不，杰斐逊不喜欢决斗。约翰·亚当斯不喜欢决斗。但如果你在军队待过，你往往会喜欢决斗。如果你来自南方，你更有可能喜欢决斗。我的意思是，很难得到决斗的精确数字，因为在许多州，决斗在技术上是非法的。
but there's an estimate that of the men who served in the Senate from southern states in the years before the American Civil War, one in five of them had taken part in jewels. I suppose this is all part of the South being the home of chivalry, isn't it? That's exactly, yeah. I mean, that's certainly their self-image, isn't it? The kind of the loss cause, the Confederacy kind of vibe. People in gigantic hats with feathers are fighting jewels or something. I'm talking about Walter Scott. Tarring for a mint dewlip after. Exactly, exactly. While in the background, they've got thousands of people being treated abominably. We'll be coming to that in the next episode as well.
但据估计，在南北战争前几年在参议院任职的南方各州议员中，五分之一的人参加过决斗。我想这都是南方作为骑士精神家园的一部分，不是吗？正是如此，是的。我的意思是，这当然是他们的自我形象，不是吗？那种“迷途的事业”、邦联的那种氛围。戴着插羽毛巨大帽子的人在决斗之类的。我说的是沃尔特·司各特。事后还要来一杯薄荷朱利酒。没错，没错。而在背景中，他们有成千上万的人受到极其恶劣的对待。我们下一集也会谈到这一点。
So this is how it works. Basically, it's very, very formalised. It's a very ritualised business for Jewel. There'll be the insult. There will be the exchange of letters. As Byrd, the offended party will say, I want you to avow or disavow your insult to me. If the offender refuses to disavow, then the victim of the insults can challenge and he and his antagonist will appoint seconds and the seconds will agree a time and place for the duel. Can I just ask? I mean, Hamilton is he is representative of the kind of the north really
所以它是这样运作的。基本上，它是非常、非常形式化的。这是一项非常仪式化的决斗业务。会有侮辱。会有信件往来。作为受冒犯的一方，伯尔会说，我要求你承认或否认你对我的侮辱。如果冒犯者拒绝否认，那么侮辱的受害者就可以发起挑战，他和他的对手将指派助手，助手们将商定决斗的时间和地点。我可以问一下吗？我的意思是，汉密尔顿，他是北方那种人的代表，
which isn't a big place for dueling and he's aligned with figures who would despise it. Would it not have been politically possible for him just to say you know, go screw yourself, I don't care. It would, but I think he, as we would discuss, he doesn't really like dueling, but I think there would have been a cost to his reputation. As we shall see, here's one of his rationales
那并不是一个盛行决斗的地方，而且他与那些鄙视决斗的人物结盟。对他来说，直接说“去你的，我不在乎”在政治上难道不可行吗？可行，但我认为，正如我们将要讨论的，他其实并不喜欢决斗，但我认为这会对他的声誉造成代价。正如我们将要看到的，他进行决斗的理由之一
for doing the jewel is he thinks public opinion would require us of him. He will look like less of a man if he had turned down the jewel. Anyway, the seconds fix the time and the place. We'll talk after the break about how the jewel itself actually works. And one reason for postponing that to after the break is that most jewels actually. actually don't get to that point. So most so-called affairs of honour never get to the point where
是他认为公众舆论会要求他这样做。如果他拒绝决斗，他看起来会显得不够男人。总之，助手们确定了时间和地点。休息后我们将讨论决斗本身实际上是如何进行的。推迟到休息后讨论的一个原因是，大多数决斗实际上并没有走到那一步。所以大多数所谓的荣誉事件从未走到
somebody actually fires a gun. It is very typical for the two men to find a solution before then, so that will allow them, a compromise, that will allow them both to preserve their honour. And Hamilton, who is, of course, as we've said, a very acerbic, very disputatious man, he has been involved in at least six affairs of honour before, but none of the them have got to the point where he actually had to pull the trigger. So in other words, they were settled in a compromise. The equivalent in today's America would be threatening to take someone to court. And that is so financially ruinous that by and large it gets settled before it comes to court. Yeah, that's a good comparison, actually. There's a sort of ritual, there's a, there's a
有人真正开枪的地步。两个人在那之前找到解决方案是非常典型的，这样可以让他们达成妥协，从而让他们双方都能保住荣誉。而汉密尔顿，正如我们所说，是一个非常尖刻、非常爱争辩的人，他之前至少参与过六次荣誉事件，但没有一次走到他真正需要扣动扳机的那一步。换句话说，它们都是通过妥协解决的。在今天的美国，等同于威胁要把某人告上法庭。而这在经济上是毁灭性的，所以大体上在诉诸法庭之前就解决了。是的，这确实是一个很好的比较。有一种仪式感，有一种
ritualistic element to take somebody to court, isn't there? And as you say, to push it to the extreme of a confrontation, you know, it's so risky. People generally don't want that. Right, exactly. Yeah. Now, Hamilton knows, he knows more than most people how risky this is, because in November 1801, his son Philip had gone into a public row with a bloke called George Ica, who had criticised Alexander Hamilton.
把某人告上法庭的仪式性因素，不是吗？正如你所说，将其推向对抗的极端，你知道，这太冒险了。人们通常不想要那样。没错，正是如此。是的。现在，汉密尔顿知道，他比大多数人都更清楚这有多冒险，因为在1801年11月，他的儿子菲利普与一个叫乔治·埃克的人发生了公开争吵，此人曾批评过亚历山大·汉密尔顿。
And Philip had challenged Ike to a duel. Hamilton said to him, well, if you're going to go and fight this duel, I advise you to miss on purpose because then you're miss and you're the challenger and that will allow the duel to be settled peacefully. But actually, for some peculiar reason, this didn't really work out. Basically, when the jewel started, both Philip Hamilton and this bloke Eka just stood there for a full minute or so, not firing, none of them really knowing what to do. And then they both sort of levelled their pistols.
菲利普向埃克发起了决斗挑战。汉密尔顿对他说，好吧，如果你要去打这场决斗，我建议你故意打偏，因为这样你打偏了，而你是挑战者，那将允许决斗和平解决。但实际上，由于某种特殊的原因，这并没有真正奏效。基本上，当决斗开始时，菲利普·汉密尔顿和这个叫埃克的家伙就站在那里整整一分钟左右，没有开枪，他们谁都不知道该怎么办。然后他们俩都把手枪平举起来。
Eka fired. Philip was wounded. and Philip died and Hamilton was absolutely grief-stricken. And I suppose Eliza as well. Yeah, it must have been. I mean, she's not going to want to lose more people from her family, is he?
埃克开枪了。菲利普受伤了，菲利普死了，汉密尔顿悲痛欲绝。我想伊丽莎也是。是的，一定是这样。我的意思是，她不会想再失去家里的其他人了，对吧？
No. So given that Hamilton knows the costs, well, this comes to your point, your question. Why did he do it? So we can understand why Burr did it. Burr did it because he's been introduced in the New York papers, he's been humiliated by the election result in New York,
不。所以考虑到汉密尔顿知道代价，嗯，这就引出了你的观点，你的问题。他为什么要这么做？我们可以理解伯尔为什么这么做。伯尔这么做是因为他在纽约报纸上被介绍，他在纽约的选举结果中受到了羞辱，
Burr is very thin-skinned, Burr is very arrogant and he wants to rebuild his reputation. But for Hamilton, this is massively high risk. He's got his wife, Eliza, he's got seven kids, he's got massive debts. So he's just built this country house in Upper Manhattan called the Grange. And it's got orchards and it's got 35 acres of woodland. It's very nice. And he has taken out a massive mortgage to pay for it,
伯尔脸皮很薄，伯尔非常傲慢，他想重建自己的声誉。但对于汉密尔顿来说，这风险极大。他有妻子伊丽莎，他有七个孩子，他背负着巨额债务。所以他刚刚在曼哈顿上城建了这座名为“格兰奇”的乡村别墅。它有果园，还有35英亩的林地。非常漂亮。他为了支付这笔费用背负了巨额抵押贷款，
which his wife would be unable to repay if he died. So he really has very little to gain. And what is more? he doesn't even agree with jewelling. And we know this because a few days before the jewel, he wrote a statement on impending duel with Aaron Burr, and he said in this statement, my religious and moral principles are strongly opposed to the practice of jewelling.
如果他死了，他的妻子将无力偿还。所以他真的几乎没有什么可得到的。而且更重要的是，他甚至不同意决斗。我们知道这一点，因为在决斗前几天，他写了一份关于与阿伦·伯尔即将进行的决斗的声明，他在声明中说，我的宗教和道德原则强烈反对决斗这种做法。
It would even give me pain to be obliged to shed the blood of a fellow creature in a private combat forbidden by the loss. But maybe he just hates Aaron Burr so much. That he's prepared to make an exception. He basically says, I can't apologize to bear it. Burr, because I meant what I said. He is despicable. He's terrible. He's a threat to the Republic. But also he says, I have to conform to public prejudice because one day I want to be
如果被迫在法律禁止的私人战斗中流下同类的血，甚至会让我感到痛苦。但也许他只是太讨厌阿伦·伯尔了。以至于他准备破例。他基本上说，我不能向伯尔道歉，因为我是认真的。他是卑劣的。他是可怕的。他是对共和国的威胁。但他也说，我必须顺应公众的偏见，因为有一天我想变得
useful, whether in resisting mischief or affecting good in those crises of public affairs which seem likely to happen. Basically, Hamilton's looking ahead. He's saying there are going to be a lot of political ructions in the next few years. The survivor of the Republic itself is at stake. I need to be popular so that I can have an effect, so I have to fight this duel. So I have to fight, not just for personal honour, but so that I can have a role in shaping the future of the country. So he agrees to the duel, very high stakes. The mad thing, though, is they don't immediately get on with it. They just hang around. And the reason is that Hamilton is still representing clients in court, and the New York courts are going to sit until the 6th of July. So they agree that they'll
有用，无论是在抵制恶行还是在那些似乎可能发生的公共事务危机中实现善行。基本上，汉密尔顿在展望未来。他说，未来几年会有很多政治动荡。共和国本身的生存岌岌可危。我需要受欢迎，这样我才能产生影响，所以我必须进行这场决斗。所以我必须战斗，不仅是为了个人荣誉，也是为了我能在塑造国家未来中发挥作用。所以他同意了决斗，赌注非常高。然而，疯狂的是，他们并没有立即开始。他们只是在那儿耗着。原因是汉密尔顿还在法庭上代理客户，而纽约法院要一直开庭到7月6日。所以他们同意
have the jewel five days later on the 11th of July. So they agree that they'll have the jewel five days later on the 11th of July so that he can finish up with all his clients. And what this means is in the meantime, the two of them have to go around New York, which of course is not an enormous place in those days. They have to hang around New York as though nothing is happening. So on Independence Day, there's a dinner organized by the Society of the Cincinnati for the former tax refusenics. And they actually sit at the same table at this dinner. Another guest who was there said, He, contrary to his want, was silent, gloomy, sour, while Hamilton entered with glee into the gaiety of a convivial party
五天后的7月11日进行决斗。所以他们同意五天后的7月11日进行决斗，这样他就可以处理完他所有的客户。这意味着在此期间，他们俩必须在纽约四处走动，当然，在那个年代，纽约并不是一个巨大的地方。他们必须在纽约晃荡，好像什么都没发生一样。所以在独立日，辛辛那提协会为那些前税务抵制者组织了一场晚宴。他们实际上在这次晚宴上坐在同一张桌子上。另一位在场的客人说，他，与往常不同，沉默、阴郁、酸楚，而汉密尔顿则兴高采烈地参与了欢聚派对的欢乐气氛，
and even sang an old military song. And this is typical of how they spend their last days before the duel. Burr keeps a low profile. He writes to his daughter Theodosia, who's got married, and he says, let me give you some advice on how to build a library. And he also writes to Theodosia's husband, new husband, and he says, I would very much appreciate it if you would allow Theodosia to carry on her studies of Latin and Greek.
甚至唱了一首古老的军歌。这就是他们度过决斗前最后几天的典型写照。伯尔保持低调。他写信给他的女儿西奥多西亚，她已经结婚了，他说，让我给你一些关于如何建立图书馆的建议。他还写信给西奥多西亚的新丈夫，他说，如果能允许西奥多西亚继续她的拉丁语和希腊语学习，我将不胜感激。
You should be warming to burn out, Tom. Does he change his will? Yeah, he does, to allow Theodosia to inherit his slaves. See, he's immediately blotted his copybook again, hasn't he? He has done, yeah. Now, Hamilton, by contrast, he's quite gregarious. He doesn't hang out, he doesn't sort of keep himself to himself. He goes to dinner parties, he visits his friends.
你应该开始对伯尔产生好感了，汤姆。他改遗嘱了吗？是的，他改了，允许西奥多西亚继承他的奴隶。你看，他立刻又把自己的名声搞臭了，不是吗？他确实做了，是的。现在，相比之下，汉密尔顿非常合群。他不躲着，他不把自己关起来。他参加晚宴，拜访朋友。
He writes a couple of letters to, two letters to Eliza, farewell letters, and he writes that statement about the jewel that I mentioned, about how he doesn't know jewelling. And in the statement he says, I've already decided on my tactics. I have resolved to reserve and throw away my first fire. And I have thoughts even of reserving my second fire and thus giving a double opportunity to Colonel Burr
他给伊丽莎写了几封信，两封告别信，他还写了那份我提到的关于决斗的声明，关于他如何不了解决斗。在声明中，他说，我已经决定了我的战术。我已下定决心保留并放弃我的第一枪。我甚至考虑保留我的第二枪，从而给伯尔上校双重机会
to pause and reflect. So this is an interesting thing because some people say, well, this was obviously Hamilton's intention. This is what he was going to do. So just to be clear what that means, to reserve and throw away my first fire, he's not going to shoot at Burr. That's what that means.
去停下来反思。所以这是一件有趣的事情，因为有些人说，嗯，这显然是汉密尔顿的意图。这就是他打算做的。所以为了明确这意味着什么，“保留并放弃我的第一枪”，他不会向伯尔开枪。这就是它的意思。
Well, he'll throw away his fire. He will shoot, but he will deliberately miss. He'll fire well wider, Burr. And what this would mean, this is not uncommon. This would give Burr the initiative, but it would also give Burr a chance to say, fair enough, let's shake hands and, you know, settle this. On the other hand, Hamilton did give his son similar advice in 1801,
嗯，他会放弃他的开火。他会开枪，但他会故意打偏。他会向远离伯尔的地方开火。这意味着什么，这并不罕见。这会给伯尔主动权，但也会给伯尔一个机会说，好吧，让我们握手言和，你知道，解决这件事。另一方面，汉密尔顿在1801年确实给了他儿子类似的建议，
and his son came back dead. Has Hamilton not learned his lesson? Clearly he hasn't. But he's done this six times. says he. He has had six affairs of honour, but they have not come to the point of shooting at all. So this is his first actual deal. Yeah.
而他的儿子回来时已经死了。汉密尔顿没有吸取教训吗？显然他没有。但他已经做了六次了，他说。他有过六次荣誉事件，但都没有走到开枪的地步。所以这是他第一次真正的决斗。是的。
And I think some historians say that the thing with this letter is, this statement is designed to be read only in the event of Hamilton's death. So you could argue it's basically a press release. It would be used after his death to black and burr's name, that Hamilton is preparing for the worst, he making himself look good and making, making burr look bad. That would be a very cynical way of looking at it, but anyway, let's get to the, towards the jewel. 7th of July, four days to go. Hamilton and Eliza throw a big garden party. They have 70 guests dining outside, they have musicians hidden in the woods, very like succession
我认为一些历史学家说，这封信的事情，这份声明旨在仅在汉密尔顿死亡的情况下阅读。所以你可以说这基本上是一份新闻稿。它会在他死后被用来抹黑伯尔的名字，汉密尔顿在为最坏的情况做准备，他让自己看起来很好，让伯尔看起来很坏。那将是一种非常愤世嫉俗的看法，但无论如何，让我们进入决斗吧。7月7日，还有四天。汉密尔顿和伊丽莎举办了一场大型花园派对。他们有70位客人在户外用餐，他们有藏在树林里的音乐家，非常像《继承之战》
or something. They have all the sort of local federalist bigwigs, and nobody suspects that there's a jewel coming, because Hamilton seems in great form. Two days later, the 9th of July, he leaves the Grange for the last time. He kisses Eliza goodbye. He rides into the the city, he goes to his townhouse, a 54 Cedar Street, Lower Manhattan. And he spends the next two nights there. And early the following morning, Wednesday, the 11th of July 1804, he wakes for the moment that will define his life and legacy the climactic jewel with Aaron Burr. Unbelievable drama. And we will find out what happens after the break. If you want a $3,000 a month payday for life, what would you feel free to do?
之类的。他们有所有当地的联邦党大人物，没有人怀疑有一场决斗即将到来，因为汉密尔顿看起来状态很好。两天后，7月9日，他最后一次离开格兰奇。他吻别了伊丽莎。他骑马进城，去了他在曼哈顿下城雪松街54号的联排别墅。他在那里度过了接下来的两个晚上。第二天清晨，1804年7月11日星期三，他醒来迎接那个将定义他一生和遗产的时刻——与阿伦·伯尔的巅峰决斗。难以置信的戏剧性。休息后我们将找出发生了什么。如果你想要每月3000美元的终身收入，你会觉得可以做什么？
Maybe take a long weekend, every weekend, or try a bunch of new hobbies. Would you feel free to upgrade and listen ad-free? Don't worry, we get it. Every $20 ticket could win you $3,000 a month for life and supports life-saving cancer research at the Princess Margaret. Feel free to buy your payday-for-life ticket today. Raffle number 155-294. Please play responsibly.
也许每个周末都休个长假，或者尝试一堆新爱好。你会觉得可以升级并享受无广告收听吗？别担心，我们懂的。每张20美元的彩票都可能让你赢得每月3000美元的终身收入，并支持玛格丽特公主医院挽救生命的癌症研究。请随时购买您的终身收入彩票。抽奖编号155-294。请负责任地参与。
Before the next track starts, have you ever wondered, who are the people in my old family photos? Or what brought them to Canada? With Ancestry, you can start finding answers. Start with a name and we'll guide you from there. For just 499, try our new 30-day Beginners Pass and uncover generations of family stories. No experience necessary.
在下一首曲目开始之前，你有没有想过，我旧家庭照片里的人是谁？或者是什么把他们带到了加拿大？通过Ancestry，你可以开始寻找答案。从一个名字开始，我们将从那里引导你。只需499，尝试我们新的30天初学者通行证，揭开几代人的家庭故事。无需经验。
You've got questions? We've got Ancestors. Offer ends July 22nd, 2026. Visit Ancestry.ca slash beginners for details. Terms apply. Hey, y'all. It's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if?
你有问题吗？我们有祖先。优惠于2026年7月22日结束。访问Ancestry.ca斜杠beginners了解详情。条款适用。嘿，大家好。我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具，然后想“万一呢”？
Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca. Wayfair, every style, every home. This episode is brought to you by the cultural phenomenon,
比如，万一它不耐用呢？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“万一”。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。访问Wayfair.ca。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。本集由文化现象赞助，
Hamilton, the musical. We know, of course, that history is about much more than dates and titles and constitutional acts. It's also built on and often driven by intense human emotion. Fear, pride, ambition, tragedy, a determination not to pay taxes. And you know, that is exactly what Lin-Manuel Miranda captures so superbly in his musical Hamilton. It lifts the curtain on the turbulent life of the founding father Alexander Hamilton from impoverished, orphan and immigrant to brilliant revolutionary.
音乐剧《汉密尔顿》。我们当然知道，历史不仅仅是日期、头衔和宪法法案。它也是建立在强烈的、往往是由强烈的人类情感驱动的。恐惧、骄傲、野心、悲剧，一种不纳税的决心。你知道，这正是林-曼努埃尔·米兰达在他的音乐剧《汉密尔顿》中如此出色地捕捉到的。它揭开了开国元勋亚历山大·汉密尔顿动荡一生的帷幕，从贫困的孤儿和移民到杰出的革命者。
250 years on from what America's persist in calling their quest for freedom, the world has absolutely fallen in love with the story of Hamilton. So it's playing in London in the Victoria Palace Theatre in New York at the Richard Rogers Theatre and it is on tour across North America. So book tickets today at Hamilton Musical.com. Hello everyone and welcome back to The Rest is History where it is early in the morning of the 11th of July 1804. And in their respective Manhattan townhouses, both Alexander Hamilton and Aaron Burr, unsurprisingly, are already up. Yeah, so Burr spent the night at his country house in Richmond Hill, Manhattan. So that's between a modern Greenwich village and Soho.
距离美国人坚持称之为追求自由的250年后，世界已经完全爱上了汉密尔顿的故事。所以它正在伦敦的维多利亚宫剧院、纽约的理查德·罗杰斯剧院上演，并且正在北美巡回演出。所以今天就在HamiltonMusical.com预订门票吧。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》，现在是1804年7月11日清晨。在他们各自的曼哈顿联排别墅里，亚历山大·汉密尔顿和阿伦·伯尔，不出所料，都已经起床了。是的，所以伯尔在曼哈顿里士满山的乡村别墅度过了一晚。所以那是在现代格林威治村和苏豪区之间。
So that was then about a mile and a half from the city of New York. And Burr got up very early. He put on this black silk coat. And he had himself driven to the quayside on the River Hudson. with his friend William Van Ness, who's going to be his second. And with a couple of other mates, Van Ness and Burr a road across the river towards Weehawken, New Jersey. Great name. And Wehawken is the chosen jewelling ground.
所以那时距离纽约市大约一英里半。伯尔起得很早。他穿上了这件黑色丝绸外套。他让朋友威廉·范内斯开车送他到哈德逊河的码头，范内斯将担任他的助手。还有另外几个伙伴，范内斯和伯尔划船穿过河流，前往新泽西州的威霍肯。好名字。威霍肯是选定的决斗场。
And the reason for this is that although dueling is forbidden in both New York and New Jersey, the New Jersey authorities are much more relaxed about prosecuting jewels. So you won't get into so much trouble. men rowing the boat, the oarsmen, they obviously know why these blokes are there, but the way this works, the oarsmen have their backs to the jewelists throughout, so that if they're asked afterwards, they can deny any knowledge. They won't be implicated in it at all. So Burr and his team arrive at about 6.30 a.m. And they've chosen this spot. It's a kind of ledge of land, about 20 feet above the river. And if you look at New York on a map, it's roughly level with
原因是，尽管纽约和新泽西都禁止决斗，但新泽西当局在起诉决斗方面要宽松得多。所以你不会惹上那么多麻烦。划船的人，桨手，他们显然知道这些家伙为什么在那儿，但它的运作方式是，桨手在整个过程中背对着决斗者，这样如果事后被问到，他们可以否认任何知情。他们根本不会卷入其中。所以伯尔和他的团队在大约早上6点30分到达。他们选择了这个地点。这是一个土地的边缘，大约在河面以上20英尺。如果你在地图上看纽约，它大致与
West 42nd Street today. And it was a very popular spot for. were jewelists. It was only a few minutes walk from the similar spot on the river where Hamilton's son Philip had been killed three years earlier. That must have concentrated his mind. Well, we'll see there were a couple of other interesting parallels. So Van Ness and another of Burr's mate start clearing the ledge. They clear the bushes away, so they'll give Burr and Hamilton some space. About half an hour later, just around seven o'clock, a second boat approaches the New Jersey side of the river. And on this boat is Hamilton, his second, who is a judge called Nathaniel Pendleton, and a doctor called David Hosak, who taught medicine at Columbia.
今天的西42街齐平。这是一个非常受欢迎的地点。是决斗者。距离三年前汉密尔顿的儿子菲利普被杀的河边类似地点只有几分钟的步行路程。那一定让他集中了精神。嗯，我们会看到还有其他几个有趣的相似之处。所以范内斯和伯尔的另一个伙伴开始清理边缘。他们清理掉灌木丛，这样他们会给伯尔和汉密尔顿一些空间。大约半小时后，就在七点左右，第二艘船靠近了河流的新泽西一侧。船上是汉密尔顿，他的助手，一位名叫纳撒尼尔·彭德尔顿的法官，以及一位名叫大卫·霍萨克的医生，他在哥伦比亚大学教授医学。
Now, usually you would have two doctors as a duel, but when the seconds discussed it with their principles, Burr said, we don't really need two doctors. Let's just get one. Another bad omen, Hosak had been on hand at the jewel on the New Jersey side of the river, where where Philip Hamilton had been killed. That's mad. Yeah, of course it's mad. It's insane. I'll tell you what I'll do.
通常决斗会有两名医生，但当助手们与他们的委托人讨论时，伯尔说，我们真的不需要两名医生。让我们只找一个吧。另一个坏兆头，霍萨克曾出现在新泽西河畔的决斗现场，菲利普·汉密尔顿就是在那里被杀的。太疯狂了。是的，当然很疯狂。这太疯狂了。我告诉你我会怎么做。
I'll have the jewel in the same place where my son was killed. I have the same doctor. What could possibly go wrong? And I'll row over the Hudson. Yeah. It's kind of like crossing the river sticks. Exactly. The whole thing is demented.
我会在我儿子被杀的同一个地方进行决斗。我有同一个医生。什么可能出错呢？而且我会划过哈德逊河。是的。这有点像渡过冥河。正是如此。整件事都疯了。
So the seconds draw lots to pick sides and they decide who's going to run the jewel. And then they hand out the pistols. And the pistols again were chosen by Hamilton. The pistols were made in London by an excellent. London gunsmith called Wogden and Barton. And they belonged to Hamilton's brother-in-law, a man called John Barker Church.
所以助手们抽签选择位置，他们决定谁来主持决斗。然后他们分发手枪。手枪又是汉密尔顿选择的。手枪是在伦敦由一位出色的伦敦枪匠沃格登和巴顿制造的。它们属于汉密尔顿的姐夫，一个叫约翰·巴克·丘奇的人。
He was British. He was the MP for Wendover. And he was married to Hamilton's sister-in-law, Angelica. So, Church, now this is a bizarre detail. Church, the bloke who gave him the pistols, had actually fought a duel with Burr himself in 1799. And nobody had been injured. These probably weren't the same pistols
他是英国人。他是温多弗的议员。他娶了汉密尔顿的嫂子安吉丽卡。所以，丘奇，现在这是一个离奇的细节。丘奇，那个给他手枪的人，实际上在1799年与伯尔本人进行过决斗。没有人受伤。这些可能不是丘奇用过的同一把手枪
that church had used. But madly, they may well be the same pistols that Hamilton's son had used in his jewel. No. Yeah. Why would you use the same pistols?
。但疯狂的是，它们很可能就是汉密尔顿的儿子在决斗中使用的同一把手枪。不。是的。为什么要用同一把手枪？
Just absolutely insane. They're very blingy, these jewelling pistols, as jewelling pistols often are. They cover with sort of brass and gold. They fire these balls, which were designed, dueling pistols were designed
简直太疯狂了。这些决斗手枪非常闪亮，正如决斗手枪通常那样。它们覆盖着黄铜和黄金。它们发射这些球，这是设计的，决斗手枪被设计成
not to be very accurate. because basically the ideal is that you'll just shoot nobody will be hit nobody will be killed and you'll both escape with your honour intact and your lives intact the pistols also though have hair triggers so a hair trigger you have to set it beforehand
不是很精确。因为基本上理想的情况是你只会开枪，没有人会被击中，没有人会被杀，你们俩都会带着荣誉和生命完好无损地逃脱。不过，手枪也有灵敏扳机，所以灵敏扳机你必须事先设置好
and what it means is that you don't have to put as much pressure on as you normally do to pull the trigger and that means you can keep your hands steadier and you'll be more accurate Pendleton Hamilton second said to Hamilton beforehand would you like me to set the hair trigger on your pistol, but not burrs? Because that would give you a big advantage.
这意味着你不需要像平时那样施加那么大的压力来扣动扳机，这意味着你可以保持手更稳，你会更精确。彭德尔顿，汉密尔顿的助手，事先对汉密尔顿说，你想让我设置你手枪上的灵敏扳机吗，但不设置伯尔的？因为那会给你一个很大的优势。
And Hamilton said, no, not this time. And historians have often wondered why Hamilton said this. I think the answer is obvious. Hamilton is very anxious. He doesn't want to be accused of cheating because that would be very bad for his reputation. Because the jewel is covered by very strict rules. We talked about the sort of ritual of it before the break. There's a thing called the Code Juello.
汉密尔顿说，不，这次不用。历史学家经常想知道汉密尔顿为什么这么说。我认为答案很明显。汉密尔顿非常焦虑。他不想被指控作弊，因为那对他的声誉非常不利。因为决斗受到非常严格的规则约束。我们在休息前谈到了决斗的仪式。有一件事叫《决斗法典》。
And the Code Juello runs like this. what you'll do is. Imagine you're fighting a duel. Who would you fight a duel with? A fight with you. Okay, fine. We'd walk away from each other for ten paces and then we would turn. And then our seconds, Alia and Tabby or whatever, Calam and Dom, they would say, they would say, are you ready?
《决斗法典》是这样运作的。你会怎么做。想象你在进行一场决斗。你会和谁决斗？和你打。好的，没问题。我们会背对背走十步，然后我们会转身。然后我们的助手，阿莉亚和塔比或者其他什么人，卡拉姆和多姆，他们会说，他们会说，你们准备好了吗？
The second who is running it, Alia's running it. She says, are you ready? Then she calls out, present. And present is your signal to fire. You're into it quite quickly. One of you fires first. It doesn't really matter who, whoever's quickest. Imagine you fire first.
主持决斗的助手，阿莉亚在主持。她说，准备好了吗？然后她喊道，瞄准。瞄准是你的开火信号。你很快就进入状态了。你们中有一个人先开火。谁先开火并不重要，谁最快。想象你先开火。
You fire, you miss shambles, you're shaking like a leaf. You haven't set your hair trigger. No, or maybe I'm just kind of, I'm very cool-handed. Yeah. But I'm compassionate and kind. Right. And I don't actually want to shoot you dead. Okay.
你开火，你打偏了，一团糟，你像一片叶子一样颤抖。你没有设置你的灵敏扳机。不，或者也许我只是有点，我非常冷静。是的。但我富有同情心和善良。对。而且我实际上不想把你射杀。好的。
So you've missed. So I aim at a kind of angle. At a tree or something, exactly. And I accidentally shoot Callum. At this point, right? my second, let's say Dom Johnson, Dom Johnson counts one, two, three, fire. And then you can shoot me.
所以你打偏了。所以我瞄准一个角度。对着一棵树什么的，正是如此。我不小心射中了卡拉姆。在这一点上，对吧？我的助手，假设是多姆·约翰逊，多姆·约翰逊数一、二、三，开火。然后你可以射我。
And now it's my turn to fire. Are you going to shoot me? I'd shoot you through the heart. Of course, you would. But maybe I wouldn't. If I chose not to, right, then I would lose my turn. Now, at this point, everybody would kind of reconvene. And the seconds would say, have the obligations of honour,
现在轮到我开火了。你要射我吗？我会射穿你的心脏。当然，你会。但也许我不会。如果我选择不这样做，对吧，那么我就会失去我的回合。现在，在这一点上，每个人都会重新聚在一起。助手们会说，荣誉的义务
been satisfied. And we'd probably agree that they had been. And that would be the end of the affair. So the vast majority of jewels, probably nine out of ten jewels, really worth stressing, do not end in anybody dying. Because even if you fire the shots, because the pistols are designed to be quite inaccurate, you're likely to miss. Generally, the jewelists will agree a deal before a single shot is fired. Who has the choice of weapons? The person who has been challenged, I think. Hamilton literally has chosen the with which his son were shot. Hamilton says in the pistols.
已经满足了吗？我们可能会同意它们已经满足了。那将是这件事的终结。所以绝大多数决斗，可能十分之九的决斗，真的值得强调，并没有以任何人死亡而告终。因为即使你开了枪，因为手枪被设计得相当不精确，你很可能会打偏。通常，决斗者会在开出一枪之前达成协议。谁有选择武器的权利？我认为是被挑战的人。汉密尔顿字面上选择了射杀他儿子的武器。汉密尔顿在手枪里说。
I mean, it would be pretty punchy for Byr to say, I'm choosing the pistols. Yeah, I know. But I wouldn't put it past him. The pistol that killed your son. I mean, that's really ours. So, Hamilton and Burr take their positions, and at this point it is highly likely that both of them will survive the jewel. Now, here's a funny detail.
我的意思是，伯尔说“我选择手枪”会非常有冲击力。是的，我知道。但我不会排除这种可能性。杀死你儿子的手枪。我的意思是，那真的很……。所以，汉密尔顿和伯尔占据了他们的位置，在这一点上，他们俩都很有可能在决斗中幸存下来。现在，这是一个有趣的细节。
Hamilton aims his pistol, and then he says, stop not to apologize to Burr and settle the jewel. He says, in certain states of the light, one requires. glasses. And he puts on these glasses and he makes a great show of squinting through them, aiming his pistol, aiming at different, aiming at burr, aiming at different things. You know, like he's getting his eye in kind of thing. And the puzzle with this is, as we know, Hamilton wrote beforehand, he said, I'm going to throw away my shot. So why is he making such a fuss about getting his eye in? I think some historians say, well, he had a death wish. He was trying
汉密尔顿瞄准了他的手枪，然后他说，停，不是为了向伯尔道歉并解决决斗。他说，在某些光线下，需要眼镜。他戴上了这些眼镜，他做出一副透过眼镜眯着眼睛的样子，瞄准他的手枪，瞄准不同的东西，瞄准伯尔，瞄准不同的东西。你知道，就像他在调整视力一样。这个谜题是，正如我们所知，汉密尔顿事先写道，他说，我要放弃我的射击。那么他为什么要为调整视力而大惊小怪呢？我认为一些历史学家说，嗯，他有死亡愿望。他试图
to provoke Burr to kill him. I think that's highly unlikely. I think he's basically just trolling Burr. He's taunting him. He's winding him up. Hamilton can't stop himself doing this. Finally he's finished. And Pendleton, the allure of the story, Pendleton says, ready, present. Now, if you've seen the musical, well, you have seen the musical, because you saw it about a week ago. You will remember, author of the musical Hamilton has been singing, I'm not throwing away my shot. but he does throw away his shot at the crucial moment. Hamilton, in the musical, he fires into the sky, a millisecond later, burr fires, straight at him, he shoots, and Hamilton falls.
挑衅伯尔杀了他。我认为这极不可能。我认为他基本上只是在钓鱼伯尔。他在嘲弄他。他在激怒他。汉密尔顿无法阻止自己这样做。最后他完成了。彭德尔顿，故事的诱惑，彭德尔顿说，准备，瞄准。现在，如果你看过音乐剧，嗯，你看过音乐剧，因为你大约一周前看过它。你会记得，音乐剧《汉密尔顿》的作者一直在唱，我不会放弃我的射击。但他确实在关键时刻放弃了他的射击。汉密尔顿，在音乐剧中，他向天空开火，一毫秒后，伯尔开火，直指他，他射击，汉密尔顿倒下。
That's what happens in the musical, but in reality what happened is much more ambiguous. So the two seconds, Pendleton and Van Ness and the doctor, Hosak, have all turned away from the action. And the reason they turn away is that if they're caught, they can deny having seen anybody firing. Jule, really? I was just out for a walk. Bird watching.
这就是音乐剧中发生的事情，但在现实中发生的事情要模糊得多。所以两个助手，彭德尔顿和范内斯，还有医生霍萨克，都背对着行动。他们背对着的原因是，如果他们被抓到，他们可以否认看到任何人开火。决斗，真的吗？我只是出来散步。观鸟。
Yeah. But all the witnesses agreed that when Pendleton shouted present, there were two shots fired within a couple of seconds of each other. And when they looked round, Burr was unscathed and Hamilton had been hit just above his right hip. And the ball entered him just above his hip in his lower abdomen. It ricocheted off his rib. It ripped through his diaphragm.
是的。但所有的证人都同意，当彭德尔顿喊出“瞄准”时，两声枪响在几秒钟内先后响起。当他们回头看时，伯尔毫发无损，而汉密尔顿被击中了右髋上方。子弹从他的髋部上方进入了他的下腹部。它从他的肋骨上反弹。它撕裂了他的横膈膜
and his liver and it lodged in his spine. And Hamilton immediately slumped the ground and he dropped his pistol. So this is the point at which they see what's happened. Burr moved towards him straight away. Pendleton said later that Burr had an expression of regret. And Burr seems, it looks like he's going to talk to Hamilton. But at this point, Burr's second, Van Ness, rushed towards him. The reason he rushed towards them is that the oars men have heard the shots
和他的肝脏，并卡在了他的脊椎里。汉密尔顿立即瘫倒在地，他丢掉了手枪。所以这就是他们看到发生了什么的时候。伯尔立刻向他走去。彭德尔顿后来表示，伯尔脸上有一种遗憾的表情。伯尔似乎，看起来他要和汉密尔顿说话。但在这一点上，伯尔的助手范内斯冲向了他。他冲向他们的原因是桨手听到了枪声
and they're coming up the slope to see what's going on. And Van Ness wants to preserve the deniability of the whole thing. So rather bizarrely, he at this point opens an umbrella which is carrying, and he hides Burr behind the umbrella and sort of hustles him towards the boats so that people can't see him. When they get to the boats, Burr says to Van Ness, I must go and speak to him, meaning Hamilton, but Van Ness says, no, no, no, no, we just have to get out of here as quickly as possible.
他们正顺着斜坡上来看看发生了什么。范内斯想保持整件事的可否认性。所以非常离奇的是，他在这一点上打开了一把随身携带的雨伞，他把伯尔藏在雨伞后面，并把他推向船只，这样人们就看不见他。当他们到达船上时，伯尔对范内斯说，我必须去和他说话，指的是汉密尔顿，但范内斯说，不，不，不，我们必须尽快离开这里。
Like, you've hit him, you've won the jewel, let's go. Now meanwhile, back on the ledge, the doctor David Hosak has rushed to Hamilton's side, and Hosak described the scene a month later, and it's worth quoting this at length. He said, I found him half sitting on the ground supported in the arms of Mr Pendleton. His countenance of death I shall never forget.
就像，你击中了他，你赢了决斗，我们走吧。现在同时，回到边缘，医生大卫·霍萨克冲到了汉密尔顿身边，霍萨克在一个月后描述了现场，值得详细引用。他说，我发现他半坐在地上，靠在彭德尔顿先生的怀里。他那死亡的面容我永远不会忘记。
He had at that instant just strength to say, This is a mortal wound, doctor, when he sunk away and became to all appearance lifeless. His pulses were not to be felt, his respiration was entirely suspended, and upon laying my hand on his heart and perceiving no motion there, I considered him as irrecoverably gone. I observed to Mr. Pendleton that the only chance for his reviving was immediately to get him upon the water. We therefore lifted him up and carried him out of the wood to the margin of the bank,
就在那一刻，他只剩下力气说：“医生，这是致命伤。”随后他便瘫软下去，看起来已毫无生气。摸不到他的脉搏，呼吸也完全停止了。我把手放在他的心口，感觉不到任何跳动，便认为他已回天乏术。我向彭德尔顿先生指出，他苏醒的唯一机会是立即把他带到水上。于是我们抬起他，把他从树林里抬到了岸边，
where the bargemen aided us in conveying him into the boat. So they're into the boat, and Hosak gets spirits and he rubs Hamilton's face with the spirits to revive him. And this does the trick. Hamilton opens his eyes, his conscious. And then he says something very interesting. He sees that his pistol is lying in the boat. And he says to the doctor, take care of that pistol. It is undischarged and still cocked.
船夫们协助我们将他送上船。他们把他抬上船后，霍萨克拿来烈酒，擦拭汉密尔顿的脸试图让他苏醒。这招奏效了。汉密尔顿睁开了眼睛，恢复了意识。接着他说了一句非常耐人寻味的话。他看到自己的手枪正躺在船上，便对医生说：“保管好那把手枪。它还没发射，而且还处于待击发状态。”
It may go off and do harm. Pendleton knows that I did not intend to fire at him, meaning burr. Now, we'll come back to this pistol because this is part of, you know, there's a mystery about this. And then Hamilton closes his eyes. He looks very calm, very peaceful. He says to Hosak, how's my pulse? He says, I have lost all feeling in my legs.
“它可能会走火伤人。”彭德尔顿知道我并没有打算向他（指伯尔）开枪。现在，我们要回到这把手枪的话题上，因为这其中有些谜团。随后汉密尔顿闭上了眼睛。他看起来非常冷静、平和。他问霍萨克：“我的脉搏怎么样？”他说：“我的双腿已经完全失去知觉了。”
and he says, Hosak said, he manifested to me that he entertained no hopes that he should long survive. But actually Hamilton is wrong. They make it back across the river. They make it back to Manhattan. And Hamilton is still breathing. And we'll come back to Hamilton in Manhattan in a second. But let's just pause the story to ask what actually happened in those crucial moments in the duel. So the most popular version of events is based on Pendleton's accounts. This is Hamilton's second. and he says the Hamilton aimed his pistol above Burr's head, but he did not fire it. Burr fired first, Burr hit Hamilton, and in the shock of being hit, Hamilton accidentally triggered his own gun. And the ball shot into a cedar tree above Burr's head.
霍萨克说，他向我表明，他对自己能否长久活下去不抱任何希望。但事实上汉密尔顿错了。他们渡过河回到了曼哈顿。汉密尔顿依然有呼吸。我们稍后再回到曼哈顿的汉密尔顿身上。但让我们先暂停故事，问问在那场决斗的关键时刻到底发生了什么。最流行的版本是基于彭德尔顿的陈述。他是汉密尔顿的助手，他说汉密尔顿将手枪瞄准了伯尔的头顶上方，但他并没有开枪。伯尔先开了枪，击中了汉密尔顿，而在中弹的冲击下，汉密尔顿不小心扣动了自己的扳机。子弹射入了伯尔头顶上方的一棵雪松里。
Pendleton went back the next day and he found a branch that had been shattered by a bullet that was 12 feet above Burr's head. And that is why Pendleton says. on the boat, Hamilton said, take care of my pistol. It's still loaded. It might go off. He didn't actually realize that it had fired.
彭德尔顿第二天回去查看，发现一根树枝被子弹击碎了，位置在伯尔头顶上方12英尺处。这就是为什么彭德尔顿说，在船上时，汉密尔顿说：“保管好我的手枪。它还装填着弹药。它可能会走火。”他实际上并没有意识到枪已经走火了。
He didn't mean to fire it. But Burr's second, Van Ness, told a different story. He said, Hamilton fired first. He did fire, and he missed. And had he deliberately missed? Well, this is the question we don't know. Van Ness actually thought Hamilton hit Burr at first because he noticed that Burr was limping,
他本无意开枪。但伯尔的助手范内斯讲述了不同的故事。他说，汉密尔顿先开了枪。他确实开了枪，但没打中。他是故意打偏的吗？嗯，这是一个我们不得而知的问题。范内斯起初确实以为汉密尔顿击中了伯尔，因为他注意到伯尔在跛行，
and he said to Burr afterwards, did Hamilton hit you? And Burr said, actually, no, I twisted my ankle when I was getting out of the boat or something. This is what Van Ness said. Hamilton fired and missed and Burr then waited.
事后他问伯尔：“汉密尔顿击中你了吗？”伯尔说：“其实没有，我下船时扭伤了脚踝之类的。”这就是范内斯所说的。汉密尔顿开枪打偏了，然后伯尔等待着。
Burr did not shoot straight away. Burr waited for Hamilton's, sorry, for the man running the jewel, Pendleton, to count to three as per the rules. But the bloat running the jewel, for whatever reason, didn't say anything. Maybe he was caught up in the moment
伯尔没有立即开枪。伯尔在等决斗的主持人，也就是彭德尔顿，按照规则数到三。但主持决斗的那个家伙，不知为何，什么也没说。也许他当时太紧张了，
or whatever. Burr was worried that he was going to lose his turn and so only after this sort of one, two, three, four, maybe five second delay, did he then shoot Hamilton because he thought, if I don't do this, I'm going to lose my turn and he might shoot me or who knows what happens. Now different historians take different views on this. Joseph Ellis, in his book on the sort of founding father's generation, he thinks this is actually plausible. He thinks that the account by Hamilton second was deliberately twisted to make Hamilton and looked like a martyr.
或者其他什么原因。伯尔担心自己会失去开枪的机会，所以在这种大约一、二、三、四，也许是五秒的延迟之后，他才向汉密尔顿开枪，因为他想：“如果我不这么做，我就会失去机会，他可能会开枪打死我，谁知道会发生什么。”现在，不同的历史学家对此有不同的看法。约瑟夫·埃利斯在他关于开国元勋那一代人的书中认为，这种说法实际上是可信的。他认为汉密尔顿助手的陈述是经过刻意扭曲的，目的是让汉密尔顿看起来像个烈士。
What's slightly confusing, though, is if that's true, if Hamilton did fire first, if he knew he fired first, why did he think the gun on the boat was still loaded? Again, Joseph Ellis says, well, maybe he was just in shock or something he didn't realize. I'm not so sure about that. Maybe a way of going through this is to go back to that letter
然而，稍微令人困惑的是，如果这是真的，如果汉密尔顿确实先开了枪，如果他知道自己先开了枪，为什么他会认为船上的枪里还有子弹？同样，约瑟夫·埃利斯说，嗯，也许他当时处于休克状态，或者什么原因没意识到。我对此不太确定。也许理清这件事的方法是回到那封信，
that Hamilton wrote beforehand, where he said, I have resolved to throw away my first fire, and then my second fire, and then giving an opportunity to purr, to pause and reflect. I think this is pretty unambiguous and I think it's very plausible that Hamilton did fire first
汉密尔顿事先写的那封信，他在信中说：“我已决定放弃我的第一次射击，然后是第二次射击，从而给伯尔一个暂停和反思的机会。”我认为这非常明确，而且我认为汉密尔顿确实先开了枪是非常可信的，
and he ostentatiously missed. That seems most likely to me. Because that's what he basically said he was going to do. Yeah. So then the question is, does Burr realize this and does Burr just deliberately kill him anyway? And the answer hangs on
而且他是故意打偏的。这对我来说似乎最有可能。因为这基本上就是他所说的他要做的事。是的。那么问题来了，伯尔意识到了这一点吗？伯尔还是故意杀了他吗？答案取决于
what you think of Burr's character. I know what your answer is going to be straight away. Yeah. He guns him down like a dog. So Joseph Ellis says, there is no way that Burr could have known that Hamilton was deliberately missing. Remember he gave Hamilton a chance to apologise and Hamilton said no. Remember that he's also seen Hamilton do all that business with the glasses.
你对伯尔性格的看法。我知道你马上会给出什么答案。是的。他像打死一条狗一样把他打死了。所以约瑟夫·埃利斯说，伯尔不可能知道汉密尔顿是故意打偏的。记住，他给了汉密尔顿道歉的机会，而汉密尔顿拒绝了。记住，他还看到汉密尔顿摆弄眼镜的那一套。
You wouldn't do that if you were trying to deliberately miss, maybe? So Hamilton's done on that stuff with his glasses, you know, practicing his aim and stuff. So Ellis says, Burr was completely within his rights. According to the principles of the code duello, Burr was perfectly justified in taking deadly aim at Hamilton and fighting. firing to kill. But Ron Cherno, in his book on Hamilton, says this is just rubbish. Chirno says, Hamilton missed by so much, by 12 feet, that it was obvious that he did it deliberately. And Bur just shot him dead like a dog, because Burr was a terrible man.
如果你是想故意打偏，你可能不会那样做，对吧？所以汉密尔顿确实做了那些摆弄眼镜的事情，你知道，练习瞄准之类的。所以埃利斯说，伯尔完全是在行使他的权利。根据决斗准则，伯尔完全有理由对汉密尔顿进行致命瞄准并开枪射杀。但罗恩·切尔诺在他关于汉密尔顿的书中说，这简直是胡说八道。切尔诺说，汉密尔顿打偏了那么多，足足12英尺，很明显他是故意的。而伯尔只是像打死一条狗一样把他打死了，因为伯尔是个可怕的人。
Chirno says, is telling that Burr said only bring one doctor. No need for two doctors. Some people might think, Burr said this because Burr thought, no one's going to get hurt anyway. We wouldn't need any doctor. Churno thinks that Burr wanted to minimise the number of doctors because he wanted to maximise the chances of Hamilton dying. So you're obviously team, Chernow. And actually, there is one other clue that backs this up. So many years later, Burr lived in exile in London
切尔诺说，伯尔只带了一名医生，这很能说明问题。没必要带两名医生。有些人可能会认为，伯尔这么说是因为他认为：“反正没人会受伤。我们不需要医生。”切尔诺认为，伯尔想尽量减少医生的数量，因为他想最大限度地提高汉密尔顿死亡的几率。所以你显然是切尔诺阵营的。事实上，还有一条线索支持这一点。多年后，伯尔在伦敦流亡，
and he became great friends, bizarrely, with the utilitarian philosopher Jeremy Bentham. Oh, that is unexpected. It is unexpected. So there's a side to Burr, Tom, that you might have enjoyed. I think Jeremy Bentham is incredibly boring. Well, anyway, Bentham said of Burr, Burr gave me an account of his duel with Hamilton,
奇怪的是，他与功利主义哲学家杰里米·边沁成了好朋友。哦，那真是出人意料。确实出人意料。所以汤姆，伯尔身上有一面你可能会喜欢。我觉得杰里米·边沁极其无聊。好吧，不管怎样，边沁谈到伯尔时说，伯尔向我讲述了他与汉密尔顿的决斗，
he was sure of being able to kill him, so I thought it little better than murder. In other words, Burr planned the whole thing. Now, my take on this, do you want to hear my take on this? Yeah, give us your take, Dominic. I think it's going to be a profound take. I think it's the unknowability of history. Of course.
他确信自己能杀了他，所以我认为这无异于谋杀。换句话说，伯尔策划了整件事。现在，我的看法是，你想听听我的看法吗？是的，说说你的看法，多米尼克。我觉得这会是一个深刻的见解。我认为这是历史的不可知性。当然。
However. Such a Lib Dem response. No, no, because I'm now going to say, I think it hinges on your understanding of the characters the two men. The one issue with Burr is his image is so clearly defined by his enemies that we can never really be sure we're seeing him clearly. But isn't it telling that he has a lot of enemies who want to paint him back? Yeah. And I did compare him with Richard Nixon before. And I think what Burr and Nixon have in common is they will, you know, they will just do
然而。真是个自由民主党的回答。不，不，因为我现在要说，我认为这取决于你对这两个人性格的理解。伯尔的一个问题是，他的形象被他的敌人定义得太清晰了，以至于我们永远无法确定我们是否看清了他。但有很多敌人想抹黑他，这难道不说明问题吗？是的。我之前确实把他和理查德·尼克松做过比较。我认为伯尔和尼克松的共同点是，他们会，你知道，他们会
anything. They will do what it takes. I mean, if Nixon was in a duel, he'd kill you. I mean, Nixon would have shot Kennedy. But actually Kennedy would have shot Nixon, I think, as well. I think and Jimmy Carter jewel. That's a jewel worth seeing. Jimmy Carter had accidentally shoot himself in the foot. He had absolutely. I wouldn't get attacked by a rabbit. He wouldn't even make it across the river. He'd be devoured by rabbits as he was trying to reach the dueling ground.
不择手段。他们会做任何必要的事。我的意思是，如果尼克松参加决斗，他会杀了你。我的意思是，尼克松会射杀肯尼迪。但我认为肯尼迪也会射杀尼克松。我想，还有吉米·卡特决斗。那是一场值得一看的决斗。吉米·卡特会不小心射中自己的脚。他绝对会。他甚至不会被兔子攻击。他在试图到达决斗场时就会被兔子吞噬。
Nixon would have shot Reagan in a duel. No question. Reagan will be telling you a focusing anecdote and then Nixon would just shoot him in the head. I mean, Trump would shoot someone in a duel. He undoubtedly would. Trump would behave disgracefully. He'd machine gun him. Trump would behave absolutely abominably in the duel, and then he'd be unrepentant afterwards.
尼克松在决斗中会射杀里根。毫无疑问。里根会给你讲一个引人入胜的轶事，然后尼克松就会直接射中他的头。我的意思是，特朗普在决斗中会射杀某人。他无疑会。特朗普会表现得极其卑劣。他会用机枪扫射他。特朗普在决斗中会表现得极其恶劣，而且事后他会毫无悔意。
Right, let's go back to the story. What happened to Hamilton? They got back across the Hudson, as I said, Hamilton's still alive. They went to a friend's house at Greenwich Village. It's obvious that Hamilton is dying. They get Eliza to come from the Grange with all seven kids and her sister, Angelica,
好了，让我们回到故事。汉密尔顿发生了什么？正如我所说，他们回到了哈德逊河对岸，汉密尔顿还活着。他们去了格林威治村的一位朋友家。很明显汉密尔顿快不行了。他们让伊丽莎带着所有七个孩子和她的妹妹安吉丽卡从格兰奇赶来，
who's staying with her. And this has come as a complete surprise to her. guess when Hamilton left the house, did he say, I'm off to fight a jewel? He left her notes and stuff, so maybe he should read them? I don't know. We just don't know, to be honest. They also got the Bishop of New York, who's a man called Benjamin Moore, and he wrote an account of afterwards what happened. Hamilton greeted him. I mean, Hamilton is dying. He's been shot in the chest, and he's in agony, and yet he still manages to say to this bishop, and people, he was impressive. He said, my dear sir, you perceive my unfortunate situation, and no doubt of
她正和她住在一起。这对她来说完全是个意外。猜猜汉密尔顿离开家时，有没有说：“我要去参加决斗了？”他给她留了字条之类的，所以也许她应该读读？我不知道。老实说，我们就是不知道。他们还找来了纽约主教，一个叫本杰明·摩尔的人，他写了一份事后发生的事情的记录。汉密尔顿迎接了他。我的意思是，汉密尔顿快死了。他胸部中弹，痛苦不堪，但他仍然设法对这位主教说，人们，他令人印象深刻。他说：“亲爱的先生，您看到了我不幸的处境，毫无疑问，您已经
made acquainted with the circumstances which led to it. It is my desire to receive the communion of your hands. I hope you will not conceive there is any impropriety in my request. I mean, there is a reason, presumably, why he is being so formal with the bishop, which is that he wants communion because he's an Episcopalian, I think, isn't he? Yes. And the bishop might say, well, I can't give it to you because you've been fighting duels. Yeah. He also surely knows the bishop's going to write this down about two days later and tell everybody about it. So he wants to look good. And Moore said to him,
了解了导致这种情况的情况。我希望能从您手中领受圣餐。我希望您不会认为我的请求有什么不妥。”我的意思是，他之所以对主教如此正式，大概是有原因的，那就是他想领受圣餐，因为我想他是圣公会教徒，对吧？是的。而主教可能会说：“好吧，我不能给你，因为你一直在参加决斗。”是的。他也肯定知道主教大约两天后会把这件事写下来并告诉所有人。所以他想表现得体。摩尔对他说：
should it please God to restore you the health, sir? Will you never again be engaged in a similar transaction? And will you employ all your influence to discountenance as barbarous custom? And Hamilton said, that sir is my deliberate intention. And so this bloke gave him communion. Hamilton later on, again with very much, I think an eye to posterity, said, I have no ill will against Colonel Burr. I met him with a fixed resolution to do him no harm.
“如果上帝保佑您恢复健康，先生，您还会再参与类似的交易吗？您会利用您所有的影响力来反对这种野蛮的习俗吗？”汉密尔顿说：“先生，那正是我的深思熟虑的意图。”于是这个家伙给了他圣餐。汉密尔顿后来，我认为同样非常着眼于后世，说：“我对伯尔上校没有任何恶意。我带着不做任何伤害他的坚定决心去见他。”
I forgive all that happened. That's an excellent way to stamp on Burr forever. Put a marker on him. So the following day of the 12th of July, he died at 2 o'clock in the afternoon. Moore said he expired without a struggle and almost without a groan. And he was buried in the Trinity Churchyard, Lower Manhattan. You can see his grave today. Now, ironically, you mentioned how he loves the National Bank.
“我原谅了发生的一切。”这真是永远抹黑伯尔的绝佳方式。给他打上一个标签。所以第二天，7月12日，他在下午2点去世了。摩尔说他走得很安详，几乎没有挣扎，也没有呻吟。他被安葬在曼哈顿下城的圣三一教堂墓地。你今天还能看到他的墓。现在，讽刺的是，你提到了他有多热爱国家银行。
His management of his own finances was poor. He left his family in massive debt. So they owed about $50,000. And if you type that into the measuring, worth calculator. I mean, that is millions and millions of dollars today. I mean, it's a feature, isn't it, of not all the founding fathers. So Franklin died very rich. John Adams was incredibly frugal. But Washington died with massive debts. Jefferson, as we will see, also has massive debts. I mean, no wonder they didn't want to pay tax. Yeah, exactly. They didn't have any money. So the mortgage,
他对自己财务的管理很糟糕。他给家人留下了巨额债务。他们欠了大约5万美元。如果你把它输入到价值计算器里。我的意思是，那相当于今天的数百万美元。我的意思是，这不是所有开国元勋的特征吗？富兰克林死时非常富有。约翰·亚当斯极其节俭。但华盛顿死时背负着巨额债务。杰斐逊，正如我们将看到的，也背负着巨额债务。我的意思是，难怪他们不想交税。是的，没错。他们根本没钱。所以抵押贷款，
as I said on the Grange was impossible for Eliza to pay. However, Hamilton's friends set up a private fund. they bought the Grange and then they sold it to her half price. So she was able to live there with her children till 1833. She devoted herself to her husband's memory. She co-founded the Orphan Asylum Society of New York and she died, age 97, having outlived Hamilton by just over 50 years. She didn't marry again? She didn't.
正如我所说，格兰奇的抵押贷款伊丽莎根本付不起。然而，汉密尔顿的朋友们设立了一个私人基金。他们买下了格兰奇，然后半价卖给了她。所以她得以和孩子们在那里住到1833年。她致力于纪念她的丈夫。她共同创立了纽约孤儿收容所协会，她去世时97岁，比汉密尔顿多活了50多年。她没有再婚吗？她没有。
She was devoted to his memory. Now, burr, what does he get up to? Even before Hamilton died, Hamilton's allies in New York were busy spinning the story and blackening Burr's name. They said that basically while Eliza was crying over her dying husband, Burr was celebrating in the taverns of New York. And they claimed that Burr was standing there at the bar of all these different pubs, you know, flagon of ale in hand, laughing and saying, I only wish I'd shot him in the heart. that drinks are on me. Yeah. I mean, this is actually just totally untrue
她致力于纪念他。现在，伯尔，他做了什么？甚至在汉密尔顿去世之前，汉密尔顿在纽约的盟友们就忙着编造故事，抹黑伯尔的名字。他们说，基本上当伊丽莎在垂死的丈夫身边哭泣时，伯尔正在纽约的酒馆里庆祝。他们声称伯尔站在所有这些不同酒吧的吧台前，你知道，手里拿着一桶麦芽酒，笑着说：“我只希望我射中了他的心脏。酒钱我请。”是的。我的意思是，这实际上完全是不真实的，
because actually what happened is that Burr fled New York straight away and he went all the way south to Georgia. Now, of course, one thing we haven't really mentioned, he's actually still the vice president of the United States. So the only parallel I can think, do you remember Dick Cheney shot that man in the face?
因为实际上发生的是伯尔立即逃离了纽约，一路向南逃到了佐治亚州。现在，当然，有一件事我们还没有真正提到，他实际上仍然是美国副总统。所以我能想到的唯一类比，你还记得迪克·切尼射中那个人的脸吗？
Yeah, we're on a duck shoot. Don't go hunting with Dick Cheney because of shoot you in the face. Anyway. Burr as Vice President He goes back to Washington He's charged with murder In both New York and New Jersey
是的，我们在打鸭子。别和迪克·切尼一起去打猎，因为他会射中你的脸。不管怎样。伯尔作为副总统，他回到华盛顿，他在纽约和新泽西都被指控谋杀，
But the case never came to trial The reason is they couldn't actually prove it Oh, because all these guys, the boatmen Facing the wrong way and things And the umbrellas and stuff Genius, brilliant God, plus him, literally no witnesses So his term as Vice President ended in 1805
但案件从未开庭审理。原因是他们实际上无法证明这一点。哦，因为所有这些家伙，船夫们，面朝错误的方向等等，还有雨伞之类的。天才，太棒了。天哪，加上他，确实没有目击者。所以他的副总统任期在1805年结束了，
But obviously his political career is now totally tainted And then in the two years After he left office Burr becomes involved in this absolutely insane conspiracy. Literally a catalytician conspiracy. So depending on which version you read, he plotted with southern planters and US army officers to create his own country on the US's southern border.
但显然他的政治生涯现在完全被玷污了。然后在离职后的两年里，伯尔卷入了这个绝对疯狂的阴谋。简直是一个催化剂阴谋。所以根据你读的版本，他与南方种植园主和美国陆军军官密谋在美国南部边境建立自己的国家。
But the mad thing about this story is that no one could agree where his country was going to be. What would you call it? Burrier. That's a terrible name. Call it Berri. Burristan. Burristan.
但这个故事最疯狂的地方在于，没有人能就他的国家要在哪里达成一致。你会叫它什么？伯尔国。那是个糟糕的名字。叫它伯尔里。伯尔斯坦。伯尔斯坦。
So some people said it was going to be Florida, some people said it was going to be northern Mexico, some people said it was going to be more than Mississippi, Alabama, Louisiana. It's just not clear at all. Burr, when he was asked, said, I just want to buy myself a nice farm. That's all I've been trying to do. The case actually went to court and he was tried for treason, but it was not proven. Basically, there were no witnesses at all and there's no evidence. Maybe they'd all had, it was the umbrellas again to come in handy.
所以有些人说它会在佛罗里达，有些人说它会在墨西哥北部，有些人说它会在密西西比、阿拉巴马、路易斯安那。根本不清楚。伯尔被问及时说：“我只是想给自己买个好农场。这就是我一直想做的。”案件实际上闹上了法庭，他因叛国罪受审，但没有被证实。基本上，根本没有目击者，也没有证据。也许他们都，又是雨伞派上用场了。
So after this, Burr went into exile in England, and then he was kicked out of him. because there were rumors that he was planning the conquest of Mexico and set himself up as king of Mexico. He wanted to go to France and Napoleon refused to allow him in it. Like if you're too bad a man for Napoleon, Napoleon said what? This bloke's marauding around, taking other people's countries. We can't have that. There's only room for one of these in my country.
所以在这之后，伯尔流亡英国，然后他被赶了出来。因为有传言说他正在策划征服墨西哥，并自立为墨西哥国王。他想去法国，但拿破仑拒绝让他进入。就像如果你对拿破仑来说太坏了，拿破仑说了什么？这个家伙在四处掠夺，占领别人的国家。我们不能那样做。我的国家里只能容得下一个这样的人。
So he wasn't allowed into France. He ended up drifting back to New York. He lived there under a false name to escape his creditors and he died in 1836. and there's one little hint that Burr regretted what happened. So at the very end of his life, he had loads of strokes, he was bedridden, and he was reading a lot of Tristram Shandy, which is commendable behaviour. And he said, and I think this really is to his credit,
所以他不被允许进入法国。他最终漂泊回了纽约。他用假名住在那里以躲避债权人，并于1836年去世。有一个小小的暗示表明伯尔后悔了发生的事情。所以在他生命的最后，他中风了很多次，卧床不起，他读了很多《项狄传》，这是值得称赞的行为。他说，我认为这确实归功于他，
if I had read Lawrence Stern more and Voltaire Less, I should have known that the world was wide enough for Hamilton and me. And that's a lesson to our listeners, that if you have the choice of Lawrence Stern or Volta, you should always read Lauren Stern. And if you want to challenge something to a deal, think again. Right, exactly. So, I mean, Bo is a very clever man and he was very brave in the war,
“如果我多读劳伦斯·斯特恩，少读伏尔泰，我就应该知道世界足够宽广，容得下汉密尔顿和我。”这对我们的听众来说是一个教训，如果你有劳伦斯·斯特恩或伏尔泰的选择，你应该总是读劳伦斯·斯特恩。如果你想挑战某人进行决斗，三思而后行。对，没错。所以，我的意思是，伯尔是一个非常聪明的人，他在战争中非常勇敢，
but he's very rarely ranked among the founding fathers. He's seen as one of American history's great villains. But of course, that's not the case for Hamilton. Hamilton becomes a martyr. There are all sorts of cities and counties named after him. There's Hamilton Heights in New York. And he's been on the $10 bill since 1929. However, Hamilton's not really as famous because he wasn't president
但他很少被列入开国元勋之列。他被视为美国历史上最伟大的恶棍之一。但当然，汉密尔顿的情况并非如此。汉密尔顿成了烈士。有各种各样的城市和县以他的名字命名。纽约有汉密尔顿高地。自1929年以来，他一直出现在10美元的钞票上。然而，汉密尔顿并没有那么出名，因为他不是总统，
as Jefferson, Adams, Washington and so on. And so in 2015, the Department of the Treasury wanted to have a woman on the currency. Who are they going to have? Abigail Adams. No. But it's got to be a founding mother. Isn't Abigail Adams the founding mother?
不像杰斐逊、亚当斯、华盛顿等等。所以2015年，财政部想在货币上印上一位女性。他们要选谁？阿比盖尔·亚当斯。不。但必须是一位开国之母。阿比盖尔·亚当斯不是开国之母吗？
She is people. The people do talk about as founding mother, but Harry Baldwin, a digital guru, correctly says Harriet Tubman. So Harriet Tubman was going to go onto the currency. Possibly it could have been Rosa Parks or someone, I suppose. Anyway, they were going to put a woman on and they said, well, obviously the person to make way as Hamilton. He's not as famous as the other as he wasn't president.
她是人们。人们确实谈论她是开国之母，但数字大师哈里·鲍德温正确地说是哈丽特·塔布曼。所以哈丽特·塔布曼要上货币。可能也可以是罗莎·帕克斯或其他人，我想。不管怎样，他们要放一位女性上去，他们说，嗯，显然要让位的人是汉密尔顿。他不像其他人那么出名，因为他不是总统。
But then just two months after that, Hamilton, the musical, transferred to Broadway. And it became a big cultural phenomenon. And the Treasury, Department of the Treasury changed their mind and said, actually, we'll keep Hamilton after all. I mean, the thing is, there wouldn't be a federal bank if it wasn't for Hamilton. Right. What I would have done is this. First of all, I'd keep Hamilton on the currency, but I think to be true to the spirit, if they want to to be slavish to the musical and to the story, be true to the spirit of it, put burr on as well,
但就在那之后两个月，音乐剧《汉密尔顿》转到了百老汇。它成了一种巨大的文化现象。财政部改变了主意，说：“实际上，我们还是保留汉密尔顿吧。”我的意思是，问题是，如果没有汉密尔顿，就不会有联邦银行。对。我会这样做。首先，我会把汉密尔顿留在货币上，但我认为要忠于精神，如果他们想忠于音乐剧和故事，忠于它的精神，也把伯尔放上去，
and have them on either side leveling pistols at each other, right? The other thing is, people may say, what, Samrock not want a woman on the currency? You are wrong. I do want a woman on the currency, and I know exactly who I would take off. I would take off a man who in his lifetime owned more than 600 human beings, a man of the most shameless and repulsive hypocrisy. And that man is the man we'll be talking about next time, and that is, of course, Thomas Jefferson. And in that episode, we will be exploring the full complexity of the man who I think is the most remarkable, the most talented of all the founding fathers, but also the most morally compromised, I guess. And members of the rest of the street club can hear that episode right away. sitting there waiting for you.
让他们在两边互相瞄准手枪，对吧？另一件事是，人们可能会说，什么，萨姆罗克不想让女性出现在货币上？你错了。我确实想让女性出现在货币上，而且我知道我确切地想去掉谁。我会去掉一个在他有生之年拥有超过600个人类，一个最无耻和令人反感的伪君子的人。那个人就是我们下次要谈论的人，当然就是托马斯·杰斐逊。在那一集中，我们将探讨这个我认为是所有开国元勋中最杰出、最有才华，但也是道德上最妥协的人的全部复杂性。而其余历史俱乐部的成员可以立即听到那一集。坐在那里等着你。
And if you're not a member of the club and you would like to hear Thomas Jefferson and also Dominant, there's a whole range of supplementary benefits. Oh, incredible benefits. We must never forget the supplementary benefits. Then go to the rest of history.com
如果你不是俱乐部的成员，并且你想听托马斯·杰斐逊以及多米尼克，还有一系列的补充福利。哦，令人难以置信的福利。我们绝不能忘记补充福利。那么去therestisistory.com
and also be able to get the incredible newsletter. So thank you, Dominic. Thanks everyone for listening. Bye-bye. Dominic, since it's the summer, I've obviously been thinking a lot about cricket. However, I am aware that the World Cup is on as well.
并且还能得到令人难以置信的时事通讯。所以谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢大家的收听。再见。多米尼克，因为是夏天，我显然一直在想板球。然而，我也意识到世界杯也在进行中。
And so occasionally, football intrudes on my mind as well. And so I've been thinking about what my historical dream football teams would be. And who would be in your historical dream team? I've numbered it down to four what I think would be the classics. And they are, of course, the Aztecs, the Royal Navy. We've got to have the Royal Navy. Ostro-Hungary. And of course, ancient Rome.
所以足球偶尔也会闯入我的脑海。所以我一直在想我的历史梦之队会是什么样子。谁会进入你的历史梦之队？我把它缩小到了四个我认为是经典的选择。它们当然是阿兹特克人、皇家海军。我们必须有皇家海军。奥匈帝国。当然，古罗马。
I mean, it's an amazing coincidence, because the rest of the army. is history have just launched football shirts for those very teams. So if there are people out there who want to know what Quahtamok would have worn during the seat of Tenochtitlan or Nelson, this is your chance to find out. And how would one, I put it bluntly, me, how would I get my hands on one, two, three, or perhaps all of these bespoke kits? You would want to head as quickly as possible to the rest is history.com and you go to the merch tab, then you would be able to pre-order one of these fantastic limited edition shirts. Would there be a way of personalising these shirts? I'm going to make you so happy now because actually there would. Each shirt can be
我的意思是，这是一个惊人的巧合，因为其余历史军队刚刚为那些球队推出了足球衫。所以如果外面有人想知道夸特莫克在特诺奇蒂特兰围城战中会穿什么，或者纳尔逊会穿什么，这是你找出答案的机会。我该如何，直言不讳地说，我，我该如何拿到一件、两件、三件，或者也许所有这些定制套件？你会想尽快前往therestisistory.com，然后去商品标签，你就能预订这些出色的限量版衬衫之一。有没有办法个性化这些衬衫？我现在要让你非常高兴，因为实际上会有。每件衬衫都可以
personalized with a choice of historical figures, the big names from that particular team. So, for example, the Royal Navy, you can go for Horatio Nelson or Emma Hamilton. You can go for Franz Ferdinand or Sophie for the Austro-Hungarian Empire. For the Aztecs, you can go for Kualtaymok, Montezuma or Malinche. Okay, these sound absolutely brilliant. The perfect way for our beloved listeners to celebrate the World Cup. And I will certainly be heading to the website and clicking on the merch page on restishistory.com. I simply cannot wait. Spotify, it's Jay Shetty. Are you one of those media strategy people? Scrolling through spreadsheets, searching for an audience that pays twice as much attention to your ads than they do on
个性化，选择历史人物，来自那支特定球队的大人物。例如，皇家海军，你可以选择霍雷肖·纳尔逊或艾玛·汉密尔顿。你可以为奥匈帝国选择弗朗茨·斐迪南或索菲。对于阿兹特克人，你可以选择夸特莫克、蒙特祖马或马林切。好的，这些听起来绝对棒极了。这是我们敬爱的听众庆祝世界杯的完美方式。我肯定会前往网站并点击restishistory.com上的商品页面。我简直等不及了。Spotify，我是杰·谢蒂。你是那些媒体策略人员之一吗？滚动浏览电子表格，寻找一个对你的广告关注度是社交媒体两倍的受众？
social? Let me introduce you to fans. And they're here with me on Spotify. Trust me, I know fans. They don't skip. They stay for hours. They don't move on. They manifest. They're not a demographic group. They're fans. Spotify advertising. among fans. Hi everybody, it's Dominic here from The Restis History. I just wanted to let you all know that on our sister podcast, The Book Club, we have just released an episode digging deep into George R.R. Martins, a Game of Thrones.
让我向你介绍粉丝。他们和我一起在Spotify上。相信我，我了解粉丝。他们不跳过。他们停留数小时。他们不继续前进。他们显现。他们不是一个人口统计群体。他们是粉丝。Spotify广告。在粉丝中。大家好，我是来自《其余历史》的多米尼克。我只是想让你们都知道，在我们的姐妹播客《读书俱乐部》中，我们刚刚发布了一集深入挖掘乔治·R·R·马丁的《权力的游戏》。
The first book in his Song of Ice and Fire sequence. We go deep into the history behind Game of Thrones, so we go into the Wars of the Roses, Hadrian's Wall. We talk about the influence of J.R. Tolkien and comparisons with the Lord of the Rings. But Tabby, we also talk, don't we, about George R.R. Martin. apparent stagnation and whether he's actually ever going to finish the books. We investigate why it is that he has battled to finish them at all and whether he will ever be able to. But if you want to hear lots more about the history behind some of the greatest novels
他《冰与火之歌》系列中的第一本书。我们深入探讨了《权力的游戏》背后的历史，所以我们进入了玫瑰战争、哈德良长城。我们谈论了J·R·R·托尔金的影响以及与《指环王》的比较。但是塔比，我们也谈论了，不是吗，关于乔治·R·R·马丁。明显的停滞以及他是否真的会完成这些书。我们调查了为什么他一直在努力完成它们，以及他是否真的能够完成。但是如果你想听到更多关于一些最伟大的小说背后的历史
of all time, Fear Not. Coming up on the book club, we have The Leopard by Giuseppe Tomasi de Lampedusa, which is all about Italian unification. We talk about Circe, where we delve into a particular part of the Odyssey. And then after that, we, are doing the 39 steps which Dominant you chose and you love. Please join us at the book club. It's loads of fun and you will never find a better way to spend your life. Bye-bye. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
的所有时间，别担心。在读书俱乐部即将推出，我们有朱塞佩·托马西·迪·兰佩杜萨的《豹》，这全是关于意大利统一的。我们谈论《喀耳刻》，我们深入研究了《奥德赛》的特定部分。然后在那之后，我们正在做多米尼克你选择并喜欢的《三十九级台阶》。请加入我们的读书俱乐部。这非常有趣，你永远找不到更好的方式来度过你的生活。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。